digital marketing is slowly becoming a
new normal marketing from banners and
billboard marketing digital marketing
has came a long way selling products on
social media platforms to make audience
notice your brand digital marketing is
continuously evolving thus creating a
lot of job opportunities in the market
on an average a digital marketing
manager earns up to 8 lakh rupees per
year in India whereas in us it is
estimated to be $90,000 per year so if
you are a aspiring digital marketer then
have a look at simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing obtain certification as
digital marketing profession through Pur
your University program acquire the
knowledge to develop and advertise your
personal website using engaging live
Interactive Learning sessions gain
Proficiency in fundamental and advanced
digital marketing techniques by engaging
with Howard business publishing cases
over 20 practical projects collaborative
interaction with chat GPT and AI tools
and access to more than 35 digital
marketing resources for admitting to
this course 2 years of experience is
preferred so hurry up and enroll Now
find the course Link in the description
box listen to what our Learners say
about our courses change is inevitable
but growth is optional for me both came
hand in hand I successfully changed my
career from software development to
digital marketing and simply learn
present at the perfect route hi I'm REM
off from Dubai and I have completed the
pgp in digital marketing from Simply
learn with puu University when I shifted
to Dubai from Sri Lanka in
2015 I joined a group of company as a
software engineer but my interest in
content creation attracted me towards
the marketing industry intrigued by the
marketing functions I decided to take up
a challenge that would change my life
forever I aimed for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
over overwhelming even though the
journey wasn't easy the pgp in digital
marketing with Fu University acted as
not only a catalyst but a game changer
for my career change with no
professional certification in marketing
domain it was difficult for me to
transition and change my career towards
completely so I decided to upskill with
a professional certification program I
chose simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be r as one
of the best Education portal online
world wi is surely promising not only
were the ratings high but also the
courses were economically charged the
modules were very informative and
amazing I still refer to those while in
the final stage of my course I told my
Superior about the certification program
I was doing and then it offered me a
digital marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive yes that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing man manager with this
my skill upgraded my salary increased
and my self-confident Boost alongside
numerous other positive outcomes I had a
chance to take a challenge and change my
career domain all together and I took it
so currently I'm pursuing masters of
Masters program from Simply learn where
I would complete eight Masters program
including artificial intelligent cloud
computing and devops and many more
growing requires moving out of our contr
zones keep learning without any further
delay over to our
tutors now let's see what digital
marketing is in simple words digital
marketing is the promotion of a product
or a brand through one or more forms of
electronic media such as Internet mobile
phones Google search engine marketing
Etc it's a way to reach client on time
and retain them with interactive
marketing using digital Technologies
also it is the most accessible easy to
use and contemporary method of promotion
which is also known as online marketing
now let's look into digital marketing
versus traditional marketing several new
and old businesses are harnessing
digital marketing and rethinking their
marketing funnels in the age of digital
marketing a digital revolution has
reshaped how we live interact and
conduct businesses traditional marketing
seems to be losing its relevance in
today's era of Technology knowing which
marketing method will work best for for
your business is essential traditional
marketing methods such as printing
material radio and television are
quickly becoming outdated they are too
expensive ineffective and time consuming
however digital marketing is the future
of advertising now let's talk about a
few reasons why digital marketing is a
better choice than traditional marketing
firstly there is a global reach a
website that allows you to find a new
market and trade globally for only a
small investment lower cost a properly
planned and well-targeted digital
marketing campaign can reach the right
customers at a much lower cost than
traditional marketing methods the next
benefit is analytics several tools are
available to analyze and report on
marketing data collected through digital
channels and the data is precious to any
business now we are on to our last
benefit which is retargeting suppose we
have a website that sells shoes and 100
people visit our website but only two
purchase the item with the help of
digital marketing we can still Target
those 98 visitors and display our ads to
them so when we want to go and promote
our product or service using a campaign
we have different options so there are
different types of digital marketing
channels that we can choose from and
let's just go through that list of
digital marketing channels and the first
one is what I consider the king of them
all and that's SEO so SEO stands for
search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the US market Google
tends or has a large market share so you
want your pages on your website to be
found and clicked on organically and so
that means if somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay and here's an example so you
type in online shopping well you can see
the first listing here is a paid search
ad we're going to get to that in a
minute the second organically is Amazon
okay so online shopping you think maybe
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or payperclick or cost per click
or PPC or CPC or sponsored search or
Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different name synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw at the previous example if you
want to be found for keyword you don't
don't have to worry about organic if
you're willing to pay for it you just
bid on that keyword and voila you have
the opportunity to appear number one in
the search results at the top of the
page for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online on shopping well my
us.com is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above Amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happen to clicked on that listing then
my us.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could could be
anywhere from one penny to $100 it
depends depends on the keyword depends
on who else is bidding on the keyword
depends on the location depends on the
time of day depends on quality score
there a lot of factors involved and
regarding what you pay however the
benefit of sem is visibility and getting
traffic to your website for keywords
you're not found for so that's why sem
such a popular choice for a lot of
companies okay let's talk talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis just an effective way to capture
leads and convert them to customers
because with email you can personalize
your emails and you can send your emails
to a segmented audience okay so if you
have emails from females who are 35
years of age to 44 that live in say the
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out you're
selling a product and the product's
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase the product
and if you purchase it you're going to
get 30% off and you can put the coupon
code right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
emo marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a Salesforce of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you could see earn up to 12%
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay out that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I wouldn't say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in
2019 and I remember talking about
Facebook back in 2006 so you're talking
about 13 14 15 years of social media
it's definitely evolved over the years
and but the concept Remains the Same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on Pinterest or
Instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on Twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media can be effective
because people use social media I mean
Facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on Facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your Social platforms
like LinkedIn and Twitter and Facebook
and Pest and Instagram they all have a
paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and you
know post content organically and hopes
of driving traffic back to your website
so with social you do have two options
here but social is interesting because
there a lot of different social media
platforms out there it really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on Facebook with Facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or com
commented on or shared or you can post
an ad and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really Distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply Tech in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're going to post
on this so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there um and depending on the platform
putting yourself out there with various
types of content so for example we look
at YouTube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you
the company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
could do a bit adjustment just for
mobile and the goal could be app
installs okay so and you can even do a
mobile or app extension so there's lots
of ways to really promote your app or
your product or your service Via mobile
marketing Rachel is a baker who runs her
own Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before for so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO search engine optimization is
a method that could improve the quality
and quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO on page and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle onpage
SEO and get that sorted onpage SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema metatags and more she
started off by using tools like Google
AdWords rref and semrush to identify
popular Search terms associated with the
recipes she planned to publish on her
blog she began to look for Search terms
related to the broader area of baking
cooking and related topics once she
found these Search terms she began to
incorporate them into her recipes she
started off by providing an introduction
to the recipe with this she could
provide an engaging beginning to her
story like how the dish reminded her of
her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time-lapses and and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website meta content that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results she optimized the metatags alt
tags header Tags and More this completed
the onpage aspect of SEO thanks to this
she saw significant increase in the
number of visitors coming to her page
having done all she could on her web
page she now decides to explore what
could be done off page to improve her
Page's visibility on search engines
off-page SEO involved Rachel doing
things outside her site page to help
increase its search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked unlink
brand mentions influencer marketing and
much more Rachel also understood that
for her content to reach people she
would have to promoted on social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter and
Instagram as well as Niche platforms
like a Reddit and medium these could
help her achieve greater reach for her
website by sending stronger social
signals to search engines leading to the
page being shown as highly relevant for
related searches and audiences and even
after understanding an implementing all
of this Rachel had just scratched the
surface of what was possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a Content two getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites three acquiring
backlinks through link buying four none
of the above let us know your answer in
the comment section below for a chance
to win an Amazon voucher now let's go
back to Rachel Rachel decided to take up
simply learn's digital marketing
certification with classes covering just
about everything she needed to know
about SEO it was only a matter of time
before Rachel began to implement her
learnings on her website and see a
massive uptick in the number of viewers
coming to her website in time she could
even earn money off the site by setting
up an online shop and with that we've
covered an introduction into the
concepts of SEO and the possibilities it
can open for you either as a marketer or
a business owner what is email marketing
well email has been around for a very
long time of course and in the very
early days there wasn't an email
marketing service that you could use
yeah you couldn't easily send out
hundreds of emails so what you did you
were actually using the BCC or the blind
carbon copy in your email system to send
out emails to many people of course the
IT department of companies in those
early days they didn't like that because
it would block the email system of the
company so they come up with little
marketing uh email Marketing Solutions
on the company's main frame but it was
all very inflexible you had to take your
email you had to take your mailing list
give that to the guy in the IT
department and if you're lucky then
maybe in a couple of days later your
email would be sent you wouldn't get any
data at all about those emails yeah you
knew how many emails were sent but you
didn't know who would have opened the
email or who would have clicked on the
email nowadays of course things are
completely different yeah now you have
email marketing where you can use email
service providers who offer you lots of
tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns so what actually is
email marketing it uses email addresses
from people to inform your email list
about your product or service we call
these commercial emails which is
completely different of course from the
billions of personal emails that are
being sent yeah around the uh the
internet every day so this is a
commercial email that you send to an
email list about your product your
service or a newsletter and what have
you Additionally you can integrate it
into your marketing automation so you
can and it can help your customers to
see your latest products and offers and
you can obviously use the email list to
and persuade them to buy or book a demo
or sign up for a trial or register for
an event yeah we call this email
nurturing where you can send a range of
emails to take people through that
journey to help them to make the
decision so what are the different uses
of email marketing it can be used in
relationship building with existing
customers who bought the product for
instance sent them a thank you email it
could be to boost brand awareness it
could be about promoting various pieces
of content it can help you in generating
leads or to promote or Market your
products and very important you can use
it to nurture leads
okay so let's have a look at what social
media marketing actually means what is
it yeah and we got to put this in the
context of the definition of
marketing yeah I studied Marketing in
the very early days in the 80s and um my
main sort of uh Guru in marketing was
Philip Cotler and over the years
marketing has sort of developed from
traditional marketing to online
marketing but the basic concept has not
changed if you look at the definition of
marketing it's the activity of creating
communicating delivering and exchanging
offerings that have value for
customers yeah so you supply you deliver
you exchange products or services that
have a value
for your
customers so two very important aspects
here there is value and there is
customer and that is what we capture in
the marketing concept you put the
customer at the core of what you do yeah
because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the
customer yep so take social media
marketing in that context then the
second part of the social media
marketing sort of term is the word
social media what is social media when I
explain social media I'm using the three
C's the three C's of social media
marketing and they are content they're
community and
campaigns content is the fuel of your
social media media content is the um the
currency of social media if you have
really good content that you can share
on the
internet yeah using various multip
multiple social media channels like
Facebook like YouTube or like video or
like Instagram or blogging you name it
yeah people will engage with your
content and then when people start
engaging with your content they may come
back for more content that you supply
and they will then become part of your
community so Community is a very
important aspect of your social media
definition with really good content you
can create
communities and then you can push that
process by running C
campaigns yeah and a campaign makes it
relevant for
businesses because when you run a
campaign you have a goal for your
campaign you have an objective you have
a St date you have an end
date yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting
content and then you put it into the
market marketing context you do that
with a customer at in the core of what
you
do yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media
marketing is very basic it says the use
of social media to develop a company's
brand increase website traffic and boost
sales that is what we call social media
marketing
yeah the most important aspect here is
that you need to have an outcome you
need to have a result which is customer
related and that is where the sales
element comes in you do this to get the
customer to do something and in the end
that is buying your product or your
service yeah so social media marketing
is not the
Tactical combination of your social
media networks yeah to um to reach as
many people there needs to be a goal to
it and when we talk about marketing it
comes down to selling your product or
service with a
value yeah so that is the um kind of the
call to action as it were that comes out
of your social media marketing so keep
that in mind everything you do with your
social media marketing in the end comes
down to reaching your goals or achieving
your objectives of developing your
company's brand increasing website
traffic or growing your
sales now a big benefit that you're
getting these days in digital marketing
and social media marketing is
data is
intelligence is
knowledge in the early days of marketing
the biggest problem has always been how
to measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and uh they write about
me in the newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I Ran So in the early pre-
interet days yeah we the only way to
measure customer engagement as it were
were through Loyalty cards or credit
cards yeah with a loyalty card you had
some basic customer data through credit
cards you could track transactions but
it's very difficult to relate that to
your marketing then the internet emerged
and all of a sudden I could track traic
to my
website yeah I could see how many people
visit my website are these people that
visit my website for the first time are
they returning visitors what are the
most popular pages that they see how
long do they stay on my website and are
they actually buying my
product yeah so that was a major
advancement of marketing in the early
2000s and then when social media emerged
it all of a sudden became possible to
measure
engagement how many people are having
conversations with us I could even
measure sentiments are people positive
about my brand are they negative about
my Brands I could track the
effectiveness of my marketing campaigns
I could measure the effectiveness of my
advertising campaigns that I ran online
so today's reality is that we can
measure everything we can measure clicks
we can measure transactions we can
measure engagements we can measure
return on
investments yeah and we can now even
take that a step further through
artificial intelligence that we can
actually start making predictions how
people may respond to campaigns that we
going to be running content marketing um
okay what is it so content marketing Is
Not A New Concept it's been around for
over a 100 years in fact one of the
classic Foundation stories of you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to the Michelin Brothers in
France and the Michelin Brothers you
know in case you haven't done your
history that's okay you know little
refresher right now were two brothers
who made pneumatic tires and they were
trying to sell them along with an
Innovative product at its time called
the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know rep Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads U but guess what
to dive for the Ratatouille H you you
got to have it this is a three star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way and since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way uh which
hotels uh you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a 2 article not
necessarily a feature and benefit what
they were doing was they were speaking
to Their audience about what Their
audience was truly passionate about
which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content but got the audience to get into
their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three star
restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know hit a pause and like well
we're doing content marketing we need to
come up with a concept think of back to
the Michelin guide it's it's a great
foundation so let's go to a modern
definition where are we now in the 21st
century when it comes to content
marketing well you can read the slide
here and read the definition and some
people like reading definitions I'm not
going to read it to you but I am going
to highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition of
content
marketing the content that you create
needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not actually meeting my needs or
interests you know and why would I be
interested in it and we've gotten way
too tired of screening out the
commercial that comes on um you know
trying to sell us snow tires and pardon
me we live in Florida I don't use snow
tires what the what the heck is this
commercial doing you know interrupting
what I'm watching
so relevance is important relevance
means that this content isn't going to
get screened out and the valuable the
valuable can can work in a lot of
different ways it can be interesting it
can be useful you know value is an
interesting proposition all by
itself but that's the key to content
marketing uh it's not just creating more
spam it's not just throwing more trash
over the fence and hoping something
happens this is something where if
you've created valuable and relevant
content you know what your customers
will find you that's a whole different
kind of
proposition I know there's some Skeptics
who saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module
3 but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create but it
can also create content for your website
and that's not the social media it can
also create content that um your PR
people can share with uh uh reporters or
bloggers and that's not normally
considered uh social media content and
by the way all of that content can be
optimized so maybe it actually is part
of of SEO not social media marketing in
fact that's the other place that content
marketing really
overlaps and it's not
coincidental it so happens that around
February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update all of a sudden even seos started
to pay attention to content marketing
why because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant you
know what it's not going to rank very
well in our search
algorithm and all of a sudden people
who' been used to like putting keywords
in the right places realized content
matters you mean I've got to actually
tell stories that are interesting I've
got to create information that's
valuable yeah yeah you can make it
relevant that's the optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash God bless you good
luck so yeah content marketing has grown
it's like tripled in terms of web search
interest since the panda update and
we're talking about Panda 1 of course
there was Panda 2 Panda three Panda four
I mean come on Google is driving us in
this direction and so content marketing
is pretty relevant today
now one of the other things that uh
people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand I do
B2B content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a
second you know content marketing has
been around now long enough and enough
people have done it but some research
has been conducted and it's been
conducted against B Toc marketers and
B2B marketers and small business
marketers and Enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like
okay we're going to try to determine
what is the difference between an
effective content marketer and an
ineffective content
marketer let's see the results well
first of all
the most important thing to Be an
Effective B Toc content
marketer is you need a documented
content
strategy oh okay all right mean people
who are winging it aren't as uh
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay no great Insight but you
know interesting to note secondly they
got to have somebody in charge who
oversees content marketing oh Lord does
that mean we have to have a reorg or
maybe we just have to designate somebody
who reports to somebody else whatever
but guess what it really helps if
somebody is driving this
process third they've got to be using
more content marketing tactics than
their less effective
peers and this is not an argument more
is better this is just pardon me that's
the way the data falls out the people
who are actually more effective are
doing more different kinds of
things a broader range of
tactics and who knows maybe it's that
broader range that's part of the success
formula same thing is true with social
media
platforms the effective content
marketers are using more than the
ineffective ones and last but not least
and this may be a sort of a result of
the first four by gosh effective content
marketers generally have greater
percentage of the overall marketing
budget in their
organization wow okay that's the BTC
marketing form but you don't understand
I'm not a b2c marketer yeah yeah yeah
okay so let's take a look at the B2B
content marketing
formula guess what you need to have a
documented content marketing strategy to
Be an Effective B2B content marketer you
need to have someone who oversees
content marketing strategy it helps if
you are using more tactics and more
social media platforms and guess what
you spend a higher percentage of your
overall marketing Budget on content
marketing well that's similar to the B
Toc content marketers but do you
understand B2B is different yeah there's
a couple small differences but guess
what overall the top five criteria are
similar and when you get to small
business here's what you're going to see
same five
criteria and you're in an Enterprise I
know the world is different for
Enterprises actually not so much so four
different data points let's net it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
I don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are you can be B Toc B2B
you can be small business you can be
large Enterprise at the end of the day
there are five things that you've got to
focus on if you want to be
effective we've already covered these
and are there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
betb and bet C well
sure but they're all at the
margin what's the downside if we don't
do this you know is anyone going to come
in and like whack us and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom but
it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your salespeople makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair and the Man in the
chair actually refers back to a classic
mcra Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks theoretically some questions from
quote maybe your salesperson okay I
don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your company's you know
reputation or anything about you and so
what was it you were going to try to
sell me and that's the downside of not
having a Content marketing
program content marketing has been
around for over 100 years but in the
online World customers are behaving in
lots of new ways and they're consuming
content on various kinds and types of
devices and that changes things content
marketing is now about creating content
that consumers will engage with and act
upon not just read or listen to or watch
so in this introductory module we're
going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decisionmaking process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions can actually
uh happen faster you can basically uh
shorten the decision making process and
you can reach and expand um to new
prospects so one of the things we hope
that you're going to uh learn after uh
basically taking this module uh you
should be able to do the following first
of all you can Define content marketing
and other related Concepts secondly you
should be able to explain why content
needs to be relevant and valuable in
order for it to be effective third you
need to describe uh the overlap between
content marketing SEO social media
marketing fourth you need to name five
traits of effective content
marketers and last but not least you
need to explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning
outcomes so content marketing Is Not A
New Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know little refresher
right now were two brothers who made
pneumatic tires and they were trying to
sell them along with an Innovative
product at its time called the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was wor going out
there for you know rep Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to dive for the Ratatouille H you
you got to have it this is a three- Star
Restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way and since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way uh which
hotels uh you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or uh tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating content
but got the audience to get into their
new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know and today we're going to
talk about affiliate marketing so let's
jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have Chuck here Chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing John walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right Chuck
responded hey I'm just worried that I
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done PID search I've done email
I've done soci
man nothing's working I got to come up
with something new ASAP well John
responds hey don't worry I think I've
got your solution for you man hang tight
relax take a load off here's my solution
affiliate marketing first off before you
ask the question what's affiliate
marketing let's talk about why we need
affiliate marketing so let's dig into
affiliate marketing so John's just
taking over now and he's going to let
Chuck know everything there is to know
about affiliate marketing so the first
question John answers for Chuck what is
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me I'm going to pay
that person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these Merchants are doing or other
enties they're advertising your product
so they're advertising your product with
a referral so they're passing on their
own customers to you so that they can
buy your product and again the exchanges
you give that website or other entity a
commission that's more or less what
affiliate marketing is so John's going
to have us take a look at each of these
components of affiliate marketing in
detail take it away John so John says
first we have the merchant AKA The Brand
the seller the Creator the founder the
owner the inspiration the innovator hey
this is the person who came up with this
brilliant idea This brilliant idea has
to get out there we're the merchant
we're trying to get this brilliant idea
out to the masses so this is the
component of affiliate marketing that
creates the product the merchant could
be anyone okay so it could be startups
to large multinational companies
International companies nonprofits
for-profits individuals independent
contractors Freelancers a group of
people who have a passion for something
okay it could be anybody there's no
limit the affiliate aka the publisher so
the affiliate is basically that
thirdparty website or entity which
promotes the Merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchants products value so this
affiliate going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular Merchants product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscription so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if I'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey I can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if I'm got this big you know
offline you know promotion that I'm
doing at this particular mall and I want
to get people there well I can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always have
to be sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for track and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in that affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen happen okay
or commissions happen you want to be
able to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so if you are an
aspiring digital marketer then have a
look at simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing obtain
certification as digital marketing
profession through Pur University
program acquire the knowledge to develop
and advertise your personal website so
hurry up and enroll Now find the cost
Link in the description box keyword
research so what are we going to talk
about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step pizza recipes
with sausage homemade pizza toppings
pizza dough recipes th Crust Pizzas
she's doing a lot of different topics on
pizza recipes well what Jesse needs to
do is understand what's going to drive
traffic to these blog posts if she's
writing about you know different topics
around pizza recipes so she's Unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to understand that
hey you need to choose use the right
keywords to drive traffic so the
question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and choosing the keywords to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen are they could have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it could be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
align with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords r
randomly without due diligence without
the proper research so low search volume
will lead to less traffic High
competition you may not even rank at all
okay if somebody finds you for a keyword
that's not relevant to the topic they're
just going to leave the page and if
you're not using the right keywords and
or if you are using the right keywords
and not using them correctly in the
content then your pages may not even be
found in organic search so you really
have to take care and choose in keywords
to me that's the most important step
with SEO is keyword research so we're
going to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three key
wordss in a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two key wordss in a
phrase or shorter so short tail keywords
usually have high search volume which
means likely means higher competition
but what it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tail keyw like
for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tail key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short tail keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with
longtail keywords chances are you're
going to have have lower competition
that's one of the benefits but you're
also going to have lower search volume
but with longer tail keywords the
keyword is probably going to be more
relevant with the content you're writing
about so therefore the conversion rates
likely going to be higher so that's
really the difference between short tail
keywords and longtail keywords if you
want to look at simplistically short
tail keywords are Broad in nature it's
going to capture a lot of eyeballs but
those eyeballs may look at your content
as not relevant versus longtail keywords
that may be very relevant but not as
many eyeballs on them so short tail
keywords the characteristics they're not
as specific usually they're less than
three words they have high search volume
and high competition so if you just
choose pizza recipes could take you a
while to rank for that keyword but when
you rank you're going to get the traffic
but again it may not convert because the
keyword is Broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyw that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long TI word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that s keyw and so the benefit of
that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tiky word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than th key words
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's it's a little bit
more uh specific in nature longer tail
so these keywords are used for targeted
Pages including blog posts if you're
writing a blog post specifically about
pizza recipes with homemade dough then
this is the keyword you likely would
want to use versus just pizza recipes so
let's look at an example between a short
tail keyword and a long tail keyword and
to accentuate the differences we're
going to use Google's Keyword Planner
tool so Google's key Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is
33,100 for pizza recipe so note that
pizza recipe and pizza recipes are
closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties a pizza recipe then they're also in
Google's eyes looking for pizza recipes
so it's a close variance and so for the
keyword pizza recipe which is short tail
we could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received
33,100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically the
volume the average volume per month so
here I can can see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is 33
1,000 and then I could see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the longtail keyword I can see
homemade pizza dough recipe again close
variance homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months what the
search volume is for this on average
it's 2400 but I could see here in
December the volume went up to 3600 but
for example in it was 19900 so it's
going to fluctuate a bit over the past
12 months but on average it's about 2400
so shorter tail lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the differences between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what Google's
Keyword Planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here I can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a lion share of those
clicks but you're going to at least
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
Promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool in Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose key words based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential tra
traffic we can obtain so again for the
key word homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all
2400 but are we're going to get a line
share of that we also need to look at
competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google's search and
I can type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about 1 billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all entitle syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitle colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to to
336,000 so what that tells me is that
there are 336,000 results with the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
now if I want to focus in on my other
keyword if I choose uh my other keyword
was a longer tail keyword homemade pizza
dough recipe so if I type that keyword
in the homemade pizza dough recipe or
recipes remember close variants and I
just click enter or type the keyword in
Hit my Enter key I'm going to get 35
Million results but again is that really
an indicator of the type of competition
I have no because every listing that
mentiones homemade pizza dough recipes
is going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
and tile colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2,160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33,100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in our volume
column what was the competition well if
we go back and type in pizza recipes it
was 683 th000 so I'm going to type in
683 th000 what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I type that keyword back
in 20
160 so I'm going to put
2,160 so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for number
different keywords and when you do it
for number keywords what you do want to
do is obviously choose a relevant
keyword that has high volume and low
competition so another way of saying it
is the volume or ratio of volume to
competition and so basically what we
could do is take volume divided by
competition and if I make that a
percentage I can see it's. 35% is the
ratio between volume of competition if I
do the same for my longer tail keyword
2400 ID by 2160 I can see that
%. so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah I'm still going to get some
volume but I have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so if somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or seasonality so for example if I saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword it's more popular
during the winter time so pay attention
to the graphs that you know the Keyword
Planner tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop at after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number number one or even on page one of
Google depending how competitive it is
so high search volume low competition in
other words the ratio between the two is
the ideal combination so going back to
the spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all en title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 Google's keyword tool so it's going
to be easy it's going to be medium it's
going to be hard but my recommendation
is also to get the numerical factor and
that's the all and title syntax and
again relevancy is what drives the
traffic to your website and keep the
traffic there on your website and also
not only will it keep the traffic on
your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find key wordss
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those key words that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial and tent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there maybe low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples like commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords as
part of your longer tail keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keywords
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a secondary
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the the content but may not necessarily
rank very high or have a lot of volume
that secondary keyword is also relevant
to the primary keyword but also relevant
to content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword I want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always always going to be relevant to
your content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is is directly related to the
content so that's what we're talking
about but these secondary keywords are
also related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to Google's Keyword Planner
tool and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy meal plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on as my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of
99,900 and then some of my secondary
keywords healthy diet foods diet plan
weight loss low carb diet you know
Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan I go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan
99,900 what's my competition so my
competition is
74,700 and that's going to give me a
ratio of volume to competition of 133%
so that's what my content's about that's
a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 133% and what I want to
do is I want to be able to put these
other secondary keywords in here as well
maybe even go to a little longer tail
because I want to be able to find two
key at least two keywords I want to be
able to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again of how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like Kora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
SE searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying lowfat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for
healthy diet then you could choose
lowfat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keyword words to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on Python and your content you want to
support that with LSI keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a keyw word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of questions
are being asked what meals are good for
weight loss what is a good healthy diet
plan all of these could be keyword
phrases that you can use so the answers
are right here in Google so core is a
great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about cor is it's a good it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing Kora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant key
words to healthy dieting so if you just
type in that particular keyword in Kora
you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use l I related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If I scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google suggesting some
other related keywords health healthy
diet menu healthy diet for men healthy
diet foods healthy diet for women so
these are all LSI related keywords that
you can use to support your primary
keyword and the content you're writing
about so we've talked about LSI keywords
where to find them so they're found
right here they could be found at the
top of Google and they could be found at
the bottom you can also then go to core
as well and get some ideas for the types
of questions they're being asked so if
you ask a question and use that as your
keyword phrase then again then you have
an opportunity of showing up for a
featured snippet in Google just by doing
some additional research within Google
itself or on Coral so according to
Google the autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for a term so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of P Pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own Advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the metad
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
Wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we could take a look at keywords from
the Wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional Pages like the see
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so we go
to Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I can
see also section so it might give me
some information food information to
Consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here in the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you go no further
than the CSA section the referencing
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags
and the Ser so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia in search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content discuss a variety of topics so
that's what Reddit is so with the help
of subreddits an individual can find
relevant keywords with with high search
volume so and Reddit there's an easy way
to find out keywords they have a keyword
tool called keyword it so keyword it is
the average monthly searches for a
particular keyword so if we type a Word
in key Reddit and choose keywords from
the autogenerator list this tool will
extract the keywords and give us those
relevant terms with search volume so if
we go to the keyword it and Show an
example of that for example healthy food
if I get keywords I can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyworded tool is going
to tell me some relevant keywords and
what the volume is so if you don't have
the Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword it.com type in your keyword
click get keywords and what it's going
to do is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar core
content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does SEO work intro to SEO
what are the basics of SEO all of those
are related to the court theme what is
SEO another cluster of key wordss for
example could be SEO techniques SEO best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization onpage SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in themes and
if we group keywords together in themes
we can apply that to a particular
content on our website so the whole idea
behind clustering keywords it's going to
provide more diversity more of an
opportunity for us to be found so that's
the whole idea behind clustering so some
additional steps remember stay up to
date on industry news so brainstorm your
ideas first and identify a list of
keywords I.E a theme of keywords that
you can cluster together and then you
could determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword MZ if I
go to keyword the keyword Explorer tool
in MZ and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see mzmz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself SEO is an
important part of the marketing strategy
in case your website doesn't show up on
the first page of the search engine then
you need to work on it to solve all your
SEO related problems we've come up with
the solution welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel and today we will be
discussing the top 10 tips that every
marketer needs to know so let's get
started and see the first step the first
step is voice search Now voice search
will impact search queries in 2021
according to dialog tech.com
in the United States of America 55% of
the households will have their own smart
speaker by
2022 well that's a lot so if you're
planning to optimize your voice search
consider choosing wise
keywords find out longer phrases that
Searchers use in daily life
conversation voice search is a more
suitable way for searching long and more
natural sounding phrases creating
detailed and relevant answers are
essential when optimizing for voice
search so always remember to create
Persona based content next create web
pages that can answer FAQ use because
when Searchers ask a question they begin
their question with words like who when
what however there are many reasons for
using voice search such as dictating
text messages looking for a video on
YouTube calling a person from your
contact list asking for directions Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is
reduced now the second step in the
process is the mobile
optimization now you must already know
how important it is to make your site
mobile friendly for a better user
experience but did you also know that
having a mobile friendly application
impacts your search engine
optimization sem Rush confirms that by
the year 2025 approximately 70% of
Internet users will access the internet
through mobile devices Google's mobile
friendly update has resulted in a big
change in search rankings with the help
of Google's free mobile friendly test
have a look at how effective your mobile
website is also take a peek at the
mobile usability ort in Google's search
console now let's talk about tip number
three that is Google's eight principles
Google has confirmed that content
quality is an essential factor for
ranking on search engine result pages
but what does quality mean to Google
well content that fulfills the Google
eat principle will rank higher eat
stands for expertise authoritativeness
and
trustworthiness these elements will
determine if a web page has a useful
quality content Google uses the
combination of algorithms to deliver the
best results for users Google Panda is
one of the famous algorithms of Google
which emphasizes delivering highquality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have lowquality and duplicate
content not just that there is one more
algorithm called rank brain rank brain
is a processing algorithm that uses
machine learning to inter seate search
queries that users search on Google
whereas the searched query may not have
the right keywords that were searched
for for example when you're searching
for chocolate cake recipes you will also
get results for chocolate truffle cake
recipes on the search engine results
page Google Panda and rankbrain send
Bots to crawl each and every website and
as a result shows high quality content
on the top of the search engine results
page next is our tip number four
featured
snippet these results are featured on
the top part of the page Google
programmatically chooses the best answer
from the thirdparty website and displays
it on the featured snippet here's what a
featured snippet looks like according to
ah refs for a specific search query
almost 99% of web pages shown in the
featured snippet already rank on sep's
first page some of the ways to optimize
featured Snippets are organize your
content in a structured way make sure
one article answers many similar
questions use eye-catching images and
the last point is to create answers with
tables to drive clicks and write
dedicated headings to answer featured
Snippets like is red meat healthy
suppose you want to create Snippets plan
on creating question-based questions
along with the relevant keywords for
ideas you can also look at the Google
search function that is usually written
in the blue color and it reads out as
people also ask so now let's move to the
fifth tip image
optimization according to sem Rush image
optimization will play a prominent role
in search in case the images on your
website aren't optimized make sure to
take care of them right now remember to
use highquality images relevant images
and use a suitable label for your image
file include images in your sit map as
it becomes easier for the Bots to crawl
and finally use alt tags as crawlers use
it to classify the images alt text is
displayed on the web page when an image
fails to load on a user screen it is
also utilized by Google to drive meaning
from images a well optimized image can
improve your page ranking and increase
the engagement on it image optimization
can help your web page show up in the
image carousels on search
engines next we have semantically
related
keywords semantic search will have
become an important factor for ranking
in the future semantic keywords are
linked to the primary keywords they
drive relevant traffic on search engine
result Pages a simple way to look for
LSI keywords is on Google SE r
p semantic search can be performed
wisely by writing content that targets
the question that your target audience
is looking for remember to optimize
content for topic clusters instead of
focusing solely on keywords and finally
use structured data and pick your
semantic keywords this can also be done
with the help of a comprehensive keyword
tool it finds out semantically related
keywords next comes tip number seven
building quality links building quality
links to your website is important if
you are aiming to manage a successful
and long-term SEO strategy building
quality links cannot be ignored in 2016
Google declared that building quality
links are one of their top three ranking
signals always opt for quality over
quantity as building quality links to
your content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in
scps let me share a few effective
strategies that will increase the number
of links pointing to your website
dramatically the first one earn
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative web pages next promote
your content regularly on social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and start your own page then
participate in forums to engage with
your target audience start your blog and
attract your target audience with your
valuable content finally get listed in
the highquality link directories this
will help you build links from
authoritative
websites next number eight is local
search
listings local SEO is the practice of
optimizing a website in order to obtain
traffic from location-based searching it
is the best way to Market your products
and services to local
customers according to Google local
results are based on relevance distance
and prominence these factors help Google
to find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the
internet sem Rush confirms that local
search listings will play a larger role
in the SEO
strategies suppose you want to know how
to get your business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own for this it is also important
to have a strong backlink
profile next we have number nine that is
improve the user experience for the past
few years ux has become an important
ranking factor for Google however more
and more SEO Specialists have gained an
interest in
ux ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor consider the
partnership of search engine
optimization and user
experience this way the search engine
optimization focuses on search engines
and user experience targets website
visitors so both share a common goal of
giving users the best result this is
what the content King app says about the
user
experience let me show you a few
practices on how to effectively leverage
ux designs to provide your site's SEO
performance simplify your site's
navigation a good site architecture
helps to gain traffic utilize ux design
to SEO friendly layouts which means make
content easy to digest infused images
and videos whenever possible use ctas
very
wisely and finally optimize for Sight
load speed optimize for mobile
responsive design as more than 50% of
all the traffic is now driven by mobile
search in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement and finally we come to our
10th and last
tip that is using schema
markup
according to search metrics 36% of
Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup schema markup is Micro
Data that every individual can add to
his website in order to give an enhanced
description to users on a search engine
results page in simple words schema
markup is used to define website
content adding structured data will give
your website a significant SEO boost and
increase your
rankings some of the schema markup
examples are ratings and reviews image
thumbnails product availability and
finally site links adding schema mark up
to your HTML is one of the ranking
factors so if you are an aspiring
digital marketer then have a look at
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing obtain certification
as digital marketing professional
through Pur University program
acquire the knowledge to develop and
advertise your personal website so hurry
up and enroll Now find the cost Link in
the description box hey guys welcome to
today's session my name is achin seel
and I'm here to talk about a very
important tool Google ads and out of all
the ads we can create under Google ads
today we would be talking about a very
important one Google search ad so this
is going to be very exciting this is
going to be very deep from my experience
I can say I will going to take you
through a lot of technical aspects and a
lot of uh optimization strategies where
you can really bring down the cost down
if you're really paying high for your
clicks and conversion so please be with
me and I would try to give you the best
from my site great so let's just start
guys Google ads is something which we
have discussed in the last class if you
have seen my last session if you have
not we will leave the link in the
description where we talked about the
basics of Google ads and we also talked
about how to create this beautiful ad
account or a tool with a free Gmail ID
okay we did talked about few more things
that how many types of ads you can
create just to give you the quick
Glimpse we are on Google and when we
type something like if I want to do a
data analytics
course so I would type few things like a
word or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called text ad or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online so then there would be results
but in a different shape and color and
different structure there is an ad which
is a text ad but on the top we are able
to see some more ads but they are not
just text they have a pricing they have
a
title they have a brand name they have a
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product uh a website like
speed test and you see the product ads
there but again in the different shape
and color so they are called display ads
because they've been displayed on
different websites and different apps so
why I'm going so fast in explaining you
different type of ads as I told you we
have another video created uh with the
name of uh Google ads uh for beginners
2023 you can just check the link in the
description and you will able to get all
this type of ads and whatever the uh you
know bidding strategies to be used in
basic in that particular tutorial or
that demo just as to show you if you can
see that adds back Google so this is the
display ad or a banner just quickly I
have shown you three types of the ads
but our Focus as I said today going to
be on a very specific ad which is the
most important ad from the Google ads
family okay so let's just begin
guys when I come to Google ads this is
how the Google ad structure looks
like we have a Google ads account
created again I repeat if you don't know
how to create it please find the link in
the description to create the Google ads
account once the Google ads account
created then you would would have a
dashboard like this okay in this
dashboard you can see there are
campaigns there are ad groups there are
ads there are videos there are landing
pages so a lot of things can be
confusing if you are just coming to this
account or to this beautiful tool for
the very first time so to just keep it
very simple or to explain in uh in a
very simpler way what I did is I just
drawn this structure for you okay so the
structure says that you have a Google
ads account imagine that I am a simply
learn Google ads manager so I am running
the ads for all simply learn keywords
like data analytics course digital
marketing course or any machine learning
course python course so whenever
somebody types this so there is a ad
which shows like from Simply learn
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simply
learn ad here so data analytics course
India and then probably we can can see
if there are any you can always change
the keywords but just to test time uh
randomly changing the words or I could
have just written simply Lear
specifically because I want to go with
simply Lear only I have researched a lot
and I feel like this is one of the best
okay so probably there is no ad
though still I will
check probably have to just change the
codes
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running because this is not a very peak
time so we are probably you know saving
some of the cost not running the ads at
this odd hour anyhow so we can assume
that this is the ad you know I am
running for so how we can create this ad
how we can get the best of clicks as I
said it is not the very best time to run
the ad so this is also kind of a change
you know we can bring into our ads by
doing some research so how all these
things are done we're going to be
learning it okay so when we come here to
the dashboard and then we see our
dashboard looks like this a bit
complicated so we can be confused we can
be disheartened that I have created the
account by seeing uh the first video but
now I am all stuck okay so probably I
have to again wait so the wait is over
now we are here to understand the whole
structure okay so let me just take a
very simple example suppose I uh am
someone who's selling a shoes okay
because I have just said simply Lear
probably let's just convert it to any of
the Google ads account of a shoe seller
probably I'm Nike okay and I am making
the ad for Nike shoes and I am selling
uh two types of the Nike shoes today
probably formal or Canvas OR probably
I'm selling the casual or any sports
shoes and what I did I created the
campaign named it search ad uh any month
you know whatever the month you have
started with suppose November so
November 2022 that is the name which I'm
giving name can be changed name is
something which is been put it up for my
reference so that after creating lot of
campaigns I'm not confused in which
campaign I have to check the results
okay so I'm running the search chart for
shoes for the month of February or
November or December 22 23 whatever and
then I open two ad groups into it why
I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I'm
selling formal also under the shoes only
I'm selling casual also so what happen
suppose I would have just you know
created one at group and would have
inserted or uh submitted all the
keywords of formal and Casual inside one
ad group then if somebody would have
searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal ad
shoes or should I show casual art shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mixed of the keywords from
formal and Casual family into the same
ad group the moment any of these six
keywords been typed or being searched on
Google then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again randomly it
would have shown the ad of a formal or
ad of a casual because both of the ads
would have been under this okay but
after doing uh this bif foration or
after doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here this ad
group would trigger if any of this
keyword would searched and accordingly
this ad which has everything related to
only formal shoes will be shown and of
course with that add the landing page
which is connected which would be open
you know when somebody clicks the ad
okay and of Versa if somebody would have
searched for a casual term like a casual
shoes sports shoes jogging shoes running
shoes then this ad group would have
triggered and then the casual shoes ad
with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shows uh you know would have opened okay
so if this is is clear actually you are
very much ready to uh dive into the
Google ads because many people takes a
lot of time to understand the structure
because uh you know maybe they are very
much confused at the ad group level but
I have just tried my level best by
bringing this example why I am creating
two different ad groups why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the
keywords second scenario could have been
or a second permutation could have been
I would have just just you know probably
created two different campaigns Al
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign Al together and I would have
named it campaign search ad casual shoes
November then this second campaign or a
second campaign can be assumed here with
you know with a green color would have
been drawn okay so this is how on the
structure it works like we can always
now create inside so let's just see few
things uh before we create the ad okay
very important uh requirement or rather
I would say uh if being the campaign
manager of any any any any any company
you name any startup you name or any
client you work with or probably for
yourself as well you have to be very
much sure or how these terms works like
Okay so this terms when I talk about is
going to be bit inclined towards the
search ad today only and when I talk
about the display ad in the next video
then I would you know take you through
about the terminologies and all the kpis
of display Banner or a video ads okay so
now if I talk about a search ad a very
important um term which we should be
aware of is the maximum bid price okay
because we all know when we talking
about this ad which is called a text ad
then we are paying on every click okay
that's why this is also called PPC ad
this is also called PPC marketing or you
can understand in a very simple words uh
Advertiser which uh is emiritus this in
this particular ad only has to pay when
somebody like such In This Moment
clicking this ad I click this ad I reach
to the landing page of this uh
particular University or this college
and
a certain amount is deducted from this
particular ad account and that certain
amount actually decides or decided on
the basis of the keyword helped to show
this ad okay so as an Advertiser must
have paid something to Google ads for
showing this ad for this keyword okay so
when I say a maximum bid price it means
it's a maximum bid price of a keyword
that's why now this would be easier to
understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course
2022 what I did I have opened the Google
Keyword Planner you know I did talked
about this in the previous session but I
will take you through again how you use
a Keyword Planner smartly so I have got
this data from the keywords planner that
the average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ADD is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have have bided something
over the minimum bid price okay this is
the minimum bid price this is the
maximum bid price okay and this is what
I've got from the Keyword Planner so
rather than going for a very high price
or the maximum bit price to secure my
position I want to play safe and what I
would do I would just take um chance
maybe 30 40% over the minimum bid range
and then I will see if the Impressions
or clicks are coming or not if this
starts coming it means that my ad is
accepted and my keyword is you know
winning in the auction and I'm able to
get the clicks but if it is not picking
then certainly I have to increase my bid
price but coming back to the
terminologies what we talking here is
once I have seted up my maximum bid
price of 7 rupees then my ad would start
showing suppose my ad shows for thousand
times today and every time when my ad
been CED you know certain amount being
deducted there is a competition there
are other advertisers also you know who
are running the ad and after showing my
ad for the whole day Google in the
dashboard just shown that you have paid
average CPC of 5 rupees only so I bid it
for seven but by seeing different uh you
know factors like the competition the
demand and how many times the ads got
clicked what was the position where my
ad was shown I ended up in paying 5
rupees for every Click by the end of a
day so the average CP
sometimes you know people get confused
they have a CPC and the maximum bid
price the same no so maximum bid price
is something which I uh you know submit
to Google that this is the maximum I can
pay for my ad to show on certain keyword
for every click and have a CPC is
something which actually you know I pay
every day or you know in that average of
the duration your ad got displayed or
got clicks uh for every uh click on that
particular keyword okay or the number of
keywords if you have more than one
keyword uh submitted and suppose I got
100 clicks then you know it's a simple
math that my budget which I have spent
today is 5 rupees for one click 500
rupees for 100 click so daily budget
would be 500 rupees and tomorrow if
company says I need 300 clicks then of
course my uh average CPC which I have
from the historical date of yesterday
you know I would just do my maths and I
will going to submit the daily budget of
not 00 rather 300 today so that in, 1500
I can expect 300 clicks at the cost of 5
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example to just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh the screenshots over
so your Keyword Planner opens and then
you discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
course and then I'll click the get
result and then accordingly it will show
me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and the high high price so
I would take the 30 40% over the low bit
price or the average price between these
both and that would be my maximum bid
price and after checking all the
permutations Google would show my ad or
either it would not show my ad also
there can be a chance so I have to just
wait for my impression and clicks and
the results by the end of a day and I
would you know I would know uh how much
the average CPC actually I'm paying for
each keyword okay so I'll show you all
those reports in a while uh that's it
right now let's just go and see few
things so the Keyword Planner will start
with suppose I start um you know in
researching all these things my campaign
is about data analytics course I'm
making it for simply probably and I
would go and I would just try to you
know search into planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know whatever I want to
show my ad for suppose
data scores as I
said okay probably let's say disal
marketing because we would have
more uh results so it's easy to
understand with a lot of results because
I would able to tell you how to sort and
filter them down uh disal marketing
course and you can just test it with any
of the keywords I'm just doing a random
check so once we are here we have lot of
keywords in addition into what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know um
monthly searches and uh of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the you
know in the month of 2021 to September
2022 so this is actually the average
monthly searches happened in between
this period and uh the advertis is
actually paid as low as 44 Rupees to as
high uh 200 24 rupees okay that can
easily be uh you know converted to
dollars uh half a dollar or maybe more
than half a dollar uh 6070 cents
probably and uh this is like going to be
a $3 cost okay so what we can do is we
can see now there are a lot of keywords
been given and we can easily sort them
down here on certain you know uh basis
like you know suppose the monthly
searches are high or the bid is low and
all that stuff but this is quite you
know difficult when we have to sort down
here in the Keyword Planner so what I do
is I'm just going to talk about the same
you know like hi how I actually go when
I working for my clients okay I have
clients here a lot of clients I don't
want to show you but yeah I have and um
suppose I just go and download this data
from here and then this would be you
know uh downloaded in the Excel format
and we can just save it anywhere suppose
I just bring it here and then now I
would open the keyword
sheet and I would have a data in my
Excel okay so I need this this one so
this is the most important column
because I have to highlight uh which
column is important and what is not
required right now so whatever is
required I'm just I'll be keeping with
me and what I feel like is not very
important as of now I'm just not going
to be taking them so now there are five
column which I have kept with myself
like these four where we talk about the
results and the keyword okay uh this is
not required this is not required I'm
just going to be deleting or hiding them
okay so when we talk about our
competition index value so this actually
tells us that a particular keyword is
how much um you know from the
competition point of view is difficult
to rank suppose I talk about two key
ones right now let me just take um one
with a lower score suppose this one and
I would take the higher or the highest
one probably is this one okay so now
when I talk about a comparison you know
probably uh or or probably let's say
this this one because this has monthly
searches which are equivalent uh you
know from the uh competition point of
view they are way different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sort that if I have
to finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that that's something
which we are talking here you know if we
have a kind of a combination where we
have to decide out of these two so both
of uh the keywords mean very important
if I would just check from my naked eye
a quick Scan they look very promising
they look very great to me suppose and
they have a equivalent number of
searches in the last uh you know one
year on the average monthly basis but
there is a difference between the
competition okay now people can be
confused what is this competition so I
would just make you explain in a very
simple way Suppose there are 100
companies or there are 100 you know at
Tech institutes or probably physical
institutes who teaches uh digital
marketing because we are doing online
marketing or you know digital marketing
course online s so let's keep it uh
online uh institutes like simply learn
and all okay so what they have done is
in the last one year they all have use
these keywords to run their ads you know
to show their uh advertisement or their
digital ad on a Google space okay when
this data has been given so this is
telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100
competitors 66 or a
66% advertisers have used this ad okay
or have used this keyword to show their
ad okay and out of 100 33% or if it is
100 uh then 33 advertisers have used
this key word to show their ad okay so
it brings you know kind of a uh
comparison to US that probably these two
keywords are very much in demand you
know like equally from the searches
point of view because both have been
searched equally but whenever this has
been searched then there has been a
competition where 66 people or 66
advertisers or 66% advertisers are
fighting to show their add okay and when
this keyword being searched as equally
then only 33% or 33 people or 33
advertisers are fighting to show their
ad on Google space okay when I talk
about 100 then that seems to be okay
where my ad would look like you know
where my ad would show because if I just
go on a Google space you know that only
seven ads are shown when you know when
we go on a Google search engine 1 2 3
and four and then the rest three would
be at the bottom if they are shown at
this moment or not I'm not very sure so
three would be here somewhere so total
seven ads placement on the first page
nobody goes beyond first we know that 97
of the worldwide audience don't go
beyond the first page ination okay so we
have to be on our first page so if I
talk about from the first page seven
positions point of view it would make
more sense so let's imagine there are
only 10 advertisers of digital marketing
course so out of 10 if I take out 60 66%
then it means almost like 6 to seven
advertisers are fighting or have bided
or probably are trying to outrank each
other to show their ad on the top or on
the first four positions of Google but
when I talk about this then only three
to four advertisers are fighting or have
bided for this keyword to show the ad on
the first page so this actually is a
very important data sometimes we just
you know Miss it because uh it has not
been uh I think explained anywhere else
that what exactly this value is we only
go by the low medium high which is the
very first column I delete nowadays you
know I don't you know go by this because
they both come under the medium but
there's a big difference you know s out
of 10 would have been bided for and only
three to four would have been bided for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
because that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bid
value or a bit uh price which is also on
a very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we try to
get the low medium competition keywords
which of course less than 60 index value
and then I put a price you know kind of
a price of my price you know which is
like if the low bid price is 10 Rupees
then I just make it 13 by adding 30% to
it so if the pricing is 10 so I would
add 30% to it that makes my price 13 and
then I check you know uh if the first
day if the Impressions has come it means
means my pricee actually been accepted
but if any of the keyword my pricee is
not accepted then I would again revise
the price by 203% and then would wait
for the second day report and that's how
you know I keep changing for the first 2
3 days and keep seeing the results and
once the you know every keyword gets
pick up and I get the you know starts
getting the stable results then I uh
just allow the campaign to work uh you
know on the algorithm and uh you know I
I see uh result actually moves in the
positive direction when you give some
time to campaigns to read and to learn
you know from the audience Behavior okay
so this is about the keyword planning
which we have just seen now moving to
again a very important aspect because
campaign making is something which I've
already given you the you know Glimpse
in the last class so I would again give
you today but before that I really you
know wanted today to speak on all these
technical aspects you know which works
at the back end so that's why my focus
is is more on this uh presentation
parallely I would keep showing you the
uh you know uh the uh Google ads uh the
demo and everything okay so now when we
move to the next part next part is very
important from the um ad algorithm point
of view so what happens or what used to
happen uh when when the quality score
you know which I'm just trying to speak
now was not there uh what used to happen
the one who used to pay the highest bid
price used to get the first position the
second one used to get the second
position and the third bidder used to
get the third position so I have just
brought into this table suppose a
Advertiser has bided 8 rupe B 10 C 15
and D 20 and when the quality score
concept was not there so they actually
been given the very direct position this
one first this one second this one third
and this one fourth but they have
realized or Google has realized that the
one who is paying the most is not having
a very good quality quality of the ad uh
his uh landing page or the website it's
is not working or probably the pages
which is which are connected are not
very relevant and the keywords on which
the ads been shown is nowhere near uh
you know when the landing page is opened
so it it was like a very negative impact
on Google when the reviews been checked
and people or the users who were
clicking on those ads were not happy so
what Google did Google brought us you
know kind of um uh test score or a check
uh which is called quality score for
every keyword we bid okay and this is
only for the search ads that's why I
said all the keywords we bid okay I'll
just show you the result on a client
site so when we submit our ad on the
basis of you know different keyword we
buid and the and the strategy we use and
the landing page we connected the back
end so what the system does is system
starts analyzing and starts checking
everything from top to you know bottom
from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every uh Advertiser here
is bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let let's um assume that they all
are running the ad for the digital
marketing course so what would happen
they would check and on the basis of the
you know factors they would give a score
out of 10 suppose the a Advertiser who
bid it for the Le East had the best of
the quality score because of the reasons
we're just going to talk about B got 8
out of 10 4 out of 10 and two out of 10
so the one who have bided the most got
the very least quality score probably
the reasons you know would be more clear
once we talk so how this now will going
to impact the whole position system is
that their Google rank not Google
position okay there is a Google rank
kind of a kPa can be understood or a
metrix which is um a product or a
multiplic ation of what you bid and how
much quality score you were able to get
so 8 into 9 brings 72 10 into 8 brings
80 15 into 4 brings 60 and 20 into 2 is
40 okay so the combination of a good
pricing and a good quality score got B
bidder as a first position okay and the
one who got the best quality score but
still paying very less from the average
pricing probably is you know brought the
Google position or ad position to Second
and then the one who was spraying very
high but the quality score was below
average which is of course 56 is average
price average score they've got into
third position and the one who was
paying so high probably would not get a
position because this is the maths from
the math point of view of got these
numbers if the quality score would have
been below five then the ad would not
have got any position rather because
Google always tries to you know show the
ads which are the best uh for the users
you know because Google always pay is
very importance to the users behavior
and users um uh you know expectations so
and when I said that I think you would
able to understand more now how the
factors you know which which actually
results in these quality score is um
like relevant score like by relevant
score means when you type A quiry or a
person would come here would type a
query so he doesn't know that this is
called a keyword we as a digital
marketers know this is called a keyword
for them it is a normal query because
they are about to start a course where
they would be taught about all these
things but right now to they are not
very aware you know very much aware of
these things so they are putting a query
when they put a query they want to see
the ad or add extensions or add
description relevant to what they have
searched and when they see all these
three things here with the search uh you
know what they made they would
definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody's clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or a first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to the query and to whatever been shown
outside they cannot just show anything
here uh which is not relevant to the ad
which has actually been shown outside so
all these uh you know uh factors uh in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is
CTR which you must have understood when
you know we uh I I did you know explain
the last session the basic one but if
you do not aware of it so CTR is called
click through rate okay and a click
through rate is a ratio of clicks to
impression okay it is a ratio of clicks
to
impression just a spell check okay so
suppose
today uh when we are saying ABCD so
let's see this this is a or this is B
and this is C and they've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their uh ad their
description everything is very much
common so Google in the starting of the
day you know when the ad actually
started to show for everyone uh you know
given them a very good quality score
probably of five okay and when this
qualty score of five been given to them
then the other factor which actually
adds on you know to that algorithm is
the CTR so CTR is I just told you is the
ratio between click to impression so now
they all have a same quality score but
this got 100 clicks out of the Thousand
Impressions being given today this got
50 clicks out of the th000 Impressions
given today this got by any mean
probably 200 clicks out of the th
Impressions given today okay every time
this this search is happening here
digital marketing course so these three
ads are very much visible equally so all
got th000 Impressions th000 Impressions
th000 Impressions but this got 100
clicks this got 50 clicks and this got
200 Clicks in the very first hour or
maybe in the next two hours okay so this
CTR you know when we are talking about
100 out of th000 to 10% This Is 50 out
of th000 it means this is going to be 5%
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of th000 means
20% of the CTR so Google was actually
benefited or made the most of the
revenue when know clicks have come from
here because it is almost like a double
or a four times of this so because of
the high CTR the quality score of of
course you know every every Advertiser
would improve but this one would be
improved from probably from 5 to 7 and
this would you know probably from 5 to
5.5 and this probably from 5 to six so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CT this ad has got so this position
will be changed and this would know
probably would get the first position
the second position and at the end of a
day this ad has to pay or Advertiser has
to pay lesser because it's quality score
increase we have just seen it is you
know almost like the uh you know
inversely proportional the ones who are
actually paying or the ones who are
having the best of the quality score are
paying the least or has to pay the least
okay so this is all basically you know
can be checked once your ad starts
running so I would just open the
client's account uh where you can just
see this
with you know bit
better understanding you would be able
to get out of
this hopefully I able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have
multiple advertisers you know but I
cannot just show for all so let me just
check if I can show you from any of the
older
one just wait it is actually asking me
some
modification it's taking too much
time yeah it's it's done now
okay so once this is
done so I just just take you to one of
the accounts where my main focus will be
to just show you how the quality score
report look like and then you know you
would get a fair idea about all the
factors you have to be focusing to bring
your quality score high or to take your
qualty score high
okay so I'm just going to open the
search ads because we're talking about a
search ad here only and suppose if I
just go into this uh Campaign which is
of course you know not running right now
but I just want to show you how to check
the report and all suppose this is the
campaign you have run for and you got 75
clicks at a you know um average CPC
price of 40 PESA and you have just given
this much pricing and I have bid it for
many keywords but I want to see which
keyword had got the best of the quality
score and how the quality score been
given and all okay so once you reach to
the keyword report here you know at this
level then you see um uh you know uh the
kpis or metrics here which gives the
quality score out of 10 okay you can see
here very well and every keyword being
given you know if if there are 10
keywords I don't know how many keywords
we bided for we bided 50 keywords okay
and um you know you can see all the
keywords here and every keyword been
given the qualty score out of 10 okay
because their CTR which was the last
part which I've explained you the ratio
between the impression two clicks got
the above average so they give uh below
average average and above average so
above average is best actually for any
of the factors so the CTR is above
average the landing page is above
average and their ad is above average
means all are perfect then they got the
10 the moment anything goes below
average or probably to the average
suppose you can see this is above
average for them this is above average
for them but their landing page
experience from this keyword point of
view is only average their quality score
has come to eight okay if you go further
down uh let's see anything where two of
them uh yeah so here the kids ride on is
a keyword where CTR is also not as high
or as great you know to as compared to
the other keywords which we have seen
and also the landing page is not as
relevant to the keyword so there are uh
two factors like CTR and landing page
has come to average as compared to the
and Rel evance which is above average so
their whole quality score got impacted
which actually came down from 10 to 8
and then 7 for this particular keyword
and last not t just take you to
somewhere where something is below
average has come now one is above
average one is okay they are getting
clicks but probably the ad is still not
very much relevant to the keyword okay
so they are below average above average
average has brought the quality score to
6 out of 10 which certainly would have
you know impacted on the cost and also
to the position okay so this is
something which you would see when you
come here also you can check one more
thing here suppose you have bided for
your keyword and your bid price where
you are paying for is maximum bid price
let me just see where that column is so
otherwise I would just add that column
so that you can learn that part as
well
[Music]
okay just wait okay so this is
basically CPC price is being given in
the average cost cost 2.50 is the cost
for every click and we got 249 clicks so
got 623 you can just check the maths
it's always good to cross check so 249
clicks multiplied by the CPC price which
is 2.50 rupe would give you
622.org
maximum bid price suppose you know you
have got the maximum bid price of 1 rupe
and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and all and
then what happens you want to secure
your position suppose the very first
page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting on a first page then here
because this campaign is not running so
I'm just giving you the hypothetical
example so whatever the pricing you
would have given for the particular
keyword suppose we talk about these
three keywords right now or particular
one keyword uh I suppose so this is
something which I'm know trying to show
on a one rupee cost but to show on the
first page it is saying that you have to
pay 1.5 okay to show on the uh first
four positions here 1 2 3 4 it is saying
that probably you have to pay 2.5 and to
get the absolute first position which is
going to be the topmost it would tell
you that you have to probably pay 5
rupee you know you're paying one it is
asking 1.5 the first four it can be paid
for 2.53 or this has to be five so you
can always go and change your you know
bid price for the particular keyword
okay so there are ways to do it suppose
if I just go here and I just go to the
edit I can change my maximum CPC bid
price for this particular bid or a
keyword like to 5 rupe okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that that particular
keyword and I have made the change to
this particular keyword to 5 rupe so if
you know the average price was one and I
was not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or first absolute position
and I want because this is the most
important keyword for me then I would
just come here and would check the
pricing okay this says 5 rupees you have
to pay for the top position so I will
just go here edit and would change the
bid price or a maximum CPC bid price of
this particular key you can do for all
you know you have to just of course you
know select all of course but if you
would do for all then it it can really
impact your whole budget okay so try to
go for the keywords where you really
feel like it is required and always go
by the quality score it has you know it
has a very good quality score so I
should be paying or I should be ready in
paying uh the maximum price which
actually Google is asking me to pay to
secure my first absolute position and uh
certainly that would increase the ch
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so conversions can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now now
I will just move to the campaign making
though we have done as I told you last
time but I will try to make it again so
that we can quickly see how the Google
ad search ads or the search Google ad
created okay so if I just go to the
campaign uh My Demo account so I just go
to the Google ads account that I mod and
then I would come to the
campaigns I would just click
plus new
campaign and whatever the you know um
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the adart
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate uh session all
together so we not doing the conversion
and remarketing today we are making a
normal search ad with all the strategies
we have just understood and with uh
adding the extensions to the ad as well
today okay website visit and suppose my
website is um just open simply
[Music]
uh landing
page so that I can make the ad for
simply andal marketing as a demo ad of
course not a main ad so copying and just
putting in here I have to just put a uh
you know website domain that's it I
don't have to bring the whole landing
page here and then I can just name it
probably
November search
add
and then I will just go and
continue start
new and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks and
of course from my Excel I would learn
that okay my bid price which I'm going
to be paying uh you know uh is certainly
in the range of something like probably
5060 and I have just told you that I
bring my price kind of a thing into this
like I always bring like this and then
let me just delete all the other column
which are not
required so this is the sheet which I
did explained you earlier with the index
value and all so my price what is my
price like so I always pay 30% 40% extra
to the low bid price so I can you know
just get the formula here like
this
plus this
30%
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 + 13 going
to bring 57 and I can just drag it and
now I've got the average suppose these
are the you know keywords which I have
finalized just assuming so these are the
keywords which I have finalized probably
because of XYZ factors searches and
index value and all that and I see that
my pricing is varying from 35 to 89 so
maximum paying 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I would going to
give the limit to my bid price that I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90 okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level and
then you move ahead and you remove this
because you just want to keep your ad on
the Google search and then you go down
you select your countries you select
your location if you want to show the ad
in all the locations then you certainly
can just go uh and keep the very first
option open which is is all countries
and territories if you want to just show
your ad um uh in a particular country
like you know right now if I just go
India so the whole India would see your
ad and if you want to go for a manual
locations like suppose I want to select
any of the states or cities then what I
would do I would just probably take
Delhi so Delhi would be targeted like
this okay or probably I just want to
Target the state of Texas here
so I just would go and Target the whole
state or if I want to Target any of the
provinces of Canada so I would just go
and take the uh provinces of Ontario
Canada and I would just Target the whole
Province and now if I also want to go
for any of the uh PIN codes suppose I
want to Target to a certain pin code
then I can just go and Target the PIN
codes like this so so it is up to us
that we want to go worldwide or if you
want to go for a country specific if you
want to go for a state specific or if
you want to go as a province or a pin
code specific okay otherwise uh if you
suppose um a restaurant or if you are a
you know somebody who only delivers into
certain radius then you can just leave
all these options and you can go and
advance search and then you can go into
radius and you can just bring this uh
whatever you understand better in India
we understand kilometers better maybe
the person in us would understand miles
better so we just go and take that 2 km
radius and probably I am the cake shop
in Delhi so I was just going to search
my location this is my location and I
was just going to Target people around 2
km because I don't deliver outside 2 km
so it's all up to us how we want to go
uh this is called radius targeting or
Geo fencing when we go to the location
we can also learn one thing suppose I
want to show the art to the um whole
country India I've targeted but the same
time I am not delivering in um uh in in
in Mumbai okay or probably in uh
Karnataka you know bangaluru where the
city is okay probably I'm not delivering
in any of the uh northern states like
harana Himachal Punjab so what I would
do I would just take Punjab suppose for
example and and I'm just going to
exclude that okay so what would happen
now my ad would show in all the states
and all the cities of India but just not
in Punjab okay so I can save it that's
how you go about the location language
is you know in which language the users
probably uses the search engine and all
so you can keep it all languages that's
the best and audience we don't cater
here much because we are doing the
search ad which actually shows the ad on
the basis of keywords and location only
so in the display we're going to talk
about this uh one and that would be the
next video I would create so we're going
to learn a lot of things from the
audience segment in the next display add
and then the more settings comes where
you talk about the ad rotation so ad
rotation is uh already default being
selected as the perform best ad uh if uh
because the nowadays the ad actually
been created uh responsive and dynamic
so when we'll reach to the ad level I'll
show you uh the headline changes for
every user the descriptions sometime
changes for the user what I mean is if
such is selecting or you know writing
this keyword so probably this headline
is shown to me and after one hour if
I'll come again and put search the same
term so the headline from the same
Advertiser could be different or the
description could be different so that's
how the dynamic ADS works like okay so
once you are done with this okay the
start and dat is important you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and then if you
want to schedule this campaign for a
certain period like suppose you don't
want to run on the weekends so you can
just select Monday to Fridays and you
know our timing whichever suits you
suppose just like a very common time of
8:00 a.m. to uh you know the late nights
like 23:45 and you don't want to run the
weekends if you want um Saturday Sunday
to be you know 24 hours then you don't
have to put any timing so that goes like
24 hours for Saturday Sundays and then
you click next and you reach to the next
next
level where it will just going to ask
you for certain things like keywords you
want to submit and the ad you want to
run for and the ad copy you know you
have to create okay so once you come
here it uh is the you know work you have
done so you can just copy paste them and
you know bring in there uh and otherwise
these all keywords are the ones which
Google has suggested you from you know
the page which you have submitted okay
so the landing page is this so I'll try
try to change the landing page first so
that I can get more appropriate keywords
and then it would going to search again
or scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show us certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords is what is the
competition of these keyword is how much
the monthly search has been so we go by
our own maths we we calculate we do all
this pre homework on the Keyword Planner
sheet just like we did today and then we
bring them here by deleting all what
they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then be ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
being used how the copy is created I'll
just show you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling
online digital marketing so I would just
going to write whatever I want to
show probably I'll just keep it
here
marketing okay so that works okay so now
it has come digital marketing and then
the part comes where you know you have
to
be I'll just going to tell you the call
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which
shows you know you know the basics so
I'll be fast again under the landing
page link this blue which actually uh
you know brings the most of the
engagement or which actually appeals the
user to click it is something in blue
which is you know going to be the
headline so we have to be focusing very
much on bringing the best of the
headlines here so that we can get the
best of the clicks because you know once
that click increases the CTR increases
CTR increases the quality score would
increase quality score would increase
your costing would come down and your
position would rise so you have to
ensure that your headlines your clicks
everything is in you know in a line
whatever we have learned so your
headline right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and I'm just
going to get the headlines as a
suggestion being given okay and um we
can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords
here this is okay this is nice this can
be
changed
digital marketing
course online is not taking so this
Marketing Online probably I'll just take
because course are already submitted and
then I can take few more like social
media marketing I just
seen whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the
rest this is the one and I should ensure
that I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know being given
like a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have a uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so
enroll or
register
today for free
demo then we'll talk
about you can see the moment I've added
the headline this the strength has
changed 100 uh
plus tools for
free
job
assistance
program okay so I'm just adding few
random things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
atank companies ads uh include some
popular keywords popular keywords could
be your brand name as well so
simply
learn
courses
online
hopefully the spelling is fine and
um
weekend batch
for
professionals
oh just a PCH for
professionals and that's it you know
because I already added a lot of
keywords lot of headlines probably R so
I would just not work on the headlines
anymore uh and I'll see you know if
description doesn't takes it high then
I'll I'll just add one more but right
now the description is also not giving
me the full uh tick like in the headline
unique and the headlines been given so
I'll just try to bring the description
so simply online online that's great
that's great I would just try to get
something from Google itself let's see
what they have given so I'll just going
to bring this one okay so that it is
been taken from the landing page itself
so that would make a difference
to uh the quality score simp digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to
put our courses focus on
skills
see focus on else like SE PPC
analytics just to bring this one here so
that it has been picked up so now you
can see this is also been picked up and
the last thing I would do is now going
to bring some headline again you know
I'll just check probably uh digital
marketing certification I'm not sure if
this headline I have submitted earlier
or not I'm just going to test it out
okay
so
training so now it has you know come
down to good and uh that's the best you
know right now we can do of course you
can take it further but yeah that
doesn't um uh matter if you are just
stuffing it to get this one completed
you have to just ensure that all the
keyword or all the headlines are
relevant just do not overdo 10 to 12 are
okay okay once this is done your ad is
created you can just click done and you
can click
next and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet when I
was explaining you so the the the bid
price which you have submitted for you
know when I told you is like something
which is in this range uh 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need um at least
100 clicks today so 90 into 100 going to
be your 9,000 daily budget so because
you know that you know you would end up
in paying maximum 90 rupees per click
because that's the maximum bid price you
have submitted if that comes down to 70
80 60 then of course your clicks would
increase but right now to being very uh
you know hypothe hypothetically think
think that okay I would pay 90 rupees
per click at Max because that is what I
submitted so to get 100 clicks I have to
pay 90 into 100 would be 9,000 your you
know daily budget has to be so you would
come here and you would just going to
change it set a custom budget and you
would going to bring down 9,000 rupees
here okay so on that CPC whatever it
would be you would get the number of
fcks if you have a CPC goes down from 90
to 45 then of course you are not going
to get only 100 rather get double amount
which is going to be 200 okay when that
is done then you just click next and
your budget goes you know your campaign
goes for a
review and then you can add the
extensions from outside okay so they're
just giving you some of the uh you know
kind of uh suggestions so let's see uh
there is one issue in the
ad let me just check that
first let me just see
you can always fix
it but that would again you're not going
to give you the option of um publishing
you know till you fix it but it is not
clickable I don't
know uh what is the
problem I just go if from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is iue
one
and okay so we just to do that
the C limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them just going to put
like skills like this
and now so these all small things you
know they
do take uh care of so here only because
we have come down so why not just to see
the extension here itself because that
would uh going to save our efforts by
going from outside so when you see the
ad you see some extensions here like you
know when you have created the ad right
now so you have created only till this
limit okay this is the elements you have
put it up right now the landing page the
headlines the description but in this ad
by emulators you can see more links like
apply to IM learn how industry so one is
landing page and three different uh
Pages or a sub page p is also been shown
in this same ad how they are done so
they are done through the extension
called site link okay so you can see
here if you go down after the headline
there's an option to have the site links
here okay so you can just click plus
here itself I'm not submitting the ad
because I wanted just to show you from
here itself and then you can go down
because in your case these would not be
given because mine are already created
yours are not so you would go down and
you would create the new new site link
from here and you can just give a name
suppose
download
brocher and then you can give a URL of
that download brocher page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page like this like
this has to be the landing page which is
workable for the downloading brocher of
course so this would be added and then I
can just go and probably add um uh
testy
monals and
reviews okay so somebody wants to read
the uh you know um testim and reviews of
when when they see the ad so you can see
that on the desktop how that would look
like so they would have an ad and then
they would have these four links and all
which you have just seen in the Google
when I shown you so final URL of reviews
can be given which would directly take
them to the page where the reviews been
given and uh site two could be anything
you know which can just see um industry
ready modules or the fee structure you
know the fee structure is something
which people always wants to just
know from the uh very first glimpse of
the art itself so I can just
maybe take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe
tools
provided now tools
and
certificates you would get so that can
also be one of the links which people
would very much interested in you know
clicking and checking okay so you would
see the the add in certain shape you
would have a normal headline uh the
description which you have put it up and
then four links where people can
directly reach okay and then you know
this had to be saved here and you can
always see the preview which I've
already shown you but yeah this is how
that would look like so you add your add
and your
four uh extra links which actually been
added okay so this is one which you can
apply
now and now your ad has the extensions
in addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your add as uh
the number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here I right now it
is not showing any of the ads with the
number but they you know uh generally
have advertisers have nowadays the
numbers in addition to the headline and
everything okay so you can add that as
well by just going up and you can see
there is an option of calls okay okay
let you can add from here uh certainly I
can show you but you know you can just
go down and add the number by clicking
your country and you know giving your
number here it it'll just be cross
checked by some verification and all so
that is done you can save it so you can
see what actually I was showing you you
know I would just show you um from
outside also that if by any of the uh
you know um that is done that we have
corrected so you don't have to be you
know uh worried about so if I just click
done so that should not be there if it
is still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about um
actually I have un acceptable spacing
contains I think I have just corrected
it but it is not taking maybe I have to
just um delete the whole description
probably that would something which I
would save our
time okay so we not adding that
description though just C done so this
is actually you know kind of a bug
because that is something which has been
deleted rather in front of you so this
is not
um taking but I would just click next
and probably this would now be not the
error in which we would see so you go
for a review so what I was saying I did
shown you from outside the you know the
the campaign was created from the ad
itself how the S site link is connected
and how the uh call being added for now
the publish campaign you can see because
that add error actually been rectified
so if by mistake you know you just
forgotten that you have to add the call
number or extension you know which we
just added so what you don't have to be
worried because once you back to the
dash board you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well you know
which you had just created then you can
just go inside the um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets let
just click
that so there's an ad which you just
created and there's an assets you know
where you could see uh
the extensions and all like you know you
just have added today we just added this
site link and this number so if I want
to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if uh that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button and then you would just go
to the call and you would see the same
kind of a preview which you have seen
inside the ad when we you're creating
okay nothing different it's just like
the you know way you do it you know
either you do when the ad was created or
otherwise you can just go uh let the
campaign be created published and you
can come from outside you can click the
add in assets you can go to plus and you
can create any of these uh extensions we
will talk about more in the coming you
know tutorials and demos uh and the
sessions but today you know we'll wind
up here I just uh you know wanted to
give you the thorough
uh learning on the Google search chart
with the extensions and also the main uh
agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can save the
cost and of course to understand how the
quality score works like you can have a
lot of videos on a YouTube where you can
find the quality score of Google ads
working though I tried to you know bring
everything under this session but still
if you want to go for a deep learning
you can always search more and research
more now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and
tricks number one set up your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make and this is exactly why
setting up goals is very important
moreover your marketing efforts have to
align with the goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a th000 conversions by the
end of the quarter or 5,000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options and number
three make sure your goals are smart now
smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy and alongside these goals there
also needs to be the Northstar metric
now what is the Northstar metric well
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular North Stars there's increased
engagement greater conversion rates more
leads generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your
audience social media allows you to
interact engage and build relationships
with your Audience by understanding what
they need need want and desire you can
deliver content in a way that makes your
product or service the answer that
they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in forums responding to their comments
and blogs and social media taking up
their feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learn's audience is predominantly
working professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
BYU app has high school students as
users now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform
now when performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there's the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest now let's talk about the
purpose of each of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences for
Facebook well just about everyone has an
account on
it content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook then we have Instagram visual
content works best on Instagram now
although it works well for static images
and short form video It Doesn't Really
drive a lot of traffic to your website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your
blog now let's go to number four setting
up a social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen posts like tag a friend who
does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media then
we have polls and surveys polls can help
you if you need a collection that also
encourages followers to take action and
interact polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and and have a high response rate and
has so much more to offer live stream
with its live nature and having a human
face alongside your business humanizes
your brand and by extension helps
increase customer loyalty and trust and
then there is infographics articles and
images so social media calendars are
successful because of their ability to
increase collaboration within the team
help understand what works and what
doesn't and in distributing resources in
an effective manner
C next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools social media marketing tools align
to the goals of your organization with
it you can create high quality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer hoot site
buzzsumo if T and much more now these
tools also help with generating leads
creating email lists finding a relevant
audience to show your content creating
buyer personas providing you insights on
what works and what doesn't and giving
you templates for different kinds of
posts now for number six visual
storytelling
visual storytelling involves passing out
a lot of information in the simplest of
forms visually using pictures and videos
your followers are able to grasp the
message quickly and remember it for a
long time afterwards visual storytelling
is also not limited by language barriers
and this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
in engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much
more but it also has some other
advantages it helps you build a bond
with your audience visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential
customers so have a look at some of our
videos so here's what is machine
learning data science in five minutes
and AI in five minutes now these are
some of our most viewed videos on our
Channel and now you know why visual
storytelling if you guys are interested
in watching these videos
you can check them out on our Channel
homepage and we also have similar videos
on blockchain devops and Six Sigma but
now back to the
list let's go to number seven paying for
advertising this is a method that helps
you find a Target and reach your
audience with ease it can greatly help
with achieving your organization's
marketing
goal and then this can help you improve
your reach and improve your Brand's
visibility it's payperclick model and
shows coste Effectiveness by providing
great results and return on investment
it also helps improve targeting by
letting you control who sees your ad you
get to choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types alongside the basic
user demographics like age location
gender and so on now since most most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
Define the performance of your ad
campaigns now as great as it sounds
there are certain pitfalls that come
along with peer advertising first of all
your audience could get exposed to your
post too many times and tune out your
content disregarding it in the
process second it could get really
expensive for small businesses or start
start ups to manage a campaign to its
maximum Effectiveness third people could
pass off your content as irrelevant or
unimportant you also have to deal with a
lot of
competition smaller companies with
lesser budgets have more of an uphill
battle to deal with than better funded
organizations next we have number eight
newsjacking newsjacking is a method that
involves using current events to promote
your own Brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness newsjacking uses
the popularity of current events and
drives it to your brand it helps shine a
spotlight on your products and it also
helps you show off that you are up
to-date with current events in the
industry and that your product is
relevant by extension it also improves
engagement and website
traffic now for number nine AB
testing AB testing is a popular method
for comparing copies creatives and ctas
or call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content AB testing helps determine which
of the variants your audience engaged
with the
most AB testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on and next up number 10 community and
influences joining communities helps
your brand link up with like minded
people and other companies belonging to
your Niche it'll also help you establish
your brand as an authority within the
industry actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential Advocates to group
up
with and on the other hand partnering up
with influencers helps promote your
products or services to a brand new
audience it helps provide an additional
layer of authenticity in YouTube which
is also a social media platform if you
didn't know here are some very very
popular influencers we have Marcus
brownley unbox therapy Mr who's the boss
and lonus Tech tips each of them with
more than 4 million
subscribers and finally we're at number
11 measuring and analyzing
results accurately tracking and
measuring your marketing efforts are an
important part of the process it ensures
that you're making the most out of your
campaigns now it's really important that
you find key metrics that are crucial
for your brand and these metrics can be
tracked weekly monthly or on a quarterly
basis and based on these results
appropriate actions can be
taken so on Facebook you could look out
for reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for Impressions clicks
and Impressions and interactions on
LinkedIn and likes comments and mentions
on Instagram and engagements and
Impressions on
Pinterest some of the most popular tools
used for this purpose are Sprout social
buffer HootSuite Google analytics and so
on so if you are an aspiring digital
marketer then have a look at simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing obtain certification as
digital marketing professional through
per University program acquire the
knowledge to develop and advertise your
personal website so hurry up and enroll
Now find the cost Link in the
description
box hello everyone welcome to this new
video by simply learn search in
optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before we
begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold so definitely we're going to
take a look at the best tips for ranking
high on Google but before that it is
necessary to understand why it's
important to to rank high on Google well
we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business the
data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as Surs allows a
business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales it also helps in
generating authenticity for your
business well not one or two there are
numerous reasons which makes SEO
important to know more about SEO check
the complete playlist on SEO you can
find the link to the playlist in the
description box below to gain expertise
in search engine optimization get
certified as a skilled SEO professional
with simply learns search engine
optimization training course you can
check the course details from the link
in the description box below as we know
how important it is to rank high on
Google so in the next 10 minutes let's
get to know the top five success mantras
that will help you rank high in Google
so the fifth tip on our list is promote
your content whether you are a business
owner or a blogger you definitely need
to promote your content to get a good
audience reach by content here we mean
data on your website that can be
products services or even a simple blog
to do this find the relevant groups on
the social media platforms like Facebook
or Instagram and post your content with
an excellent call to action context some
blogging or article submission sites
like Kora Tumblr and hub pages may also
prove helpful online forums and
communities can be a good option to
spread a word about your content with
people having similar interests let's
focus on our number four tip internal
linking a good site architecture is
always a happy bite for webcrawlers a
website with good site architecture and
internal linking helps webcrawlers
understand the website structure and
helps them to crawl the site more
effectively the more the pages of your
website are crawled greater are the
chances of getting indexed if pages are
successfully indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below and number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results on page
optimization onpage optimization or also
known as onpage SEO is a process in
which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web pages
position in search engine rankings
onpage optimization is a last concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more get the detail guide to learning
onpage optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research keyword research is a process
of identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create proper keyword research
may prove a boon to your business but it
also has the power to ruin your business
so be wise When selecting your keywords
try choosing longtail keywords if you
are new to the business as these are
easier to rank for you can look at
Google's Autos suggest feature to
understand what people are looking for
in your industry be updated with what
your competitors are doing if something
is working for your competitor there are
high chances that it may work for you as
well you can also take the help of
various keyword research tools like
Google's own Keyword Planner answer the
public tool Google Trends and Etc these
fantastic and 100% practical tips can
drive your business to Heights make sure
you implement all these tips with more
detailed attention as SEO can make and
break you so what according to you is
the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments Below in the age of digital
marketing it is very easy to get lost in
the sea of information if you are a
beginner you will probably spend a lot
of time reading and researching even if
you are an expert you will still need to
keep up to date and know what's going on
in the marketing world but how do you
find the time to do do that how do you
find the time to stay on top of Trends
and Innovations we have compiled a list
of 20 plus digital marketing tools to
help you make your life easier some of
these tools might sound familiar to you
and some might sound new and interesting
we believe all of them have some value
in your life and can assist you in
staying on top of Trends hey everyone
I'm Tushar Bal welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel in this video we will
understand 20 plus digital marketing
tools to grow your business in 2022 but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned so
without any further delay let's get
started with the plan for today's
session first we will look at the
research part next we will explore tools
to build or host a website content is
king So next we will have a look at some
of the best content creation tools to
grow your business moving forward we
will disc discuss designing and Graphics
tools once designing is done it's time
to promote and hence we will look at the
best promotional tools after that we
will discuss some great email marketing
tools user behavior and computer
analysis tools and finally we will end
the session by understanding the
communication tools that will help your
business operate smoothly research
research is one of the most essential
parts of getting your business to the
next level it's what turns an idea into
a real business however it is hard to do
research without the right tools luckily
there are many tools out there that do
the job perfectly here are just few that
you need to know about Uber suggest Uber
suggest is a free tool that produces
fresh keyword ideas it is among the best
free tools available on the market
however it has a Premium plan for
advanced features but it is best if you
are starting out and it has some good
features like you will get the search
volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas
Keyword Planner it is one of the best
free tools and the best part is that
it's a Google product so that the data
can be trusted you can use Google
Keyword Planner to do keyword research
Google Keyword Planner will show you the
monthly search volume of keywords and
phrases the average cost per click in
your selected country and how difficult
it is to rank for the keywords some of
the best features are you will get the
custom time based keyword data and get
to know the competition on that keyword
hrfs hrfs is one of the most advanced
tool available for keyword research it
is also used for competitor analysis
rank tracking and site auditing xf's
main features are geared towards
marketer but you can also use it to find
keywords for Google YouTube and Amazon
the tool is paid but suitable for
businesses looking for in-depth
information it has some features like
rank tracker that will help you know
your existing website ranking and the
second one is alert you will get
important information or stats by mail
after doing the research part you need a
website for your business let's have a
look at how to do that the first step in
creating a website is to find a place to
host it there are many options out there
and depending on what your site will be
used for you may need different tools
web hosting tools have evolved to meet
the online community's need better it
can be challenging to select the right
one through many options here are the
few of the best tools available on the
market WordPress it will help you create
your website by just drag and dropping
no coding is required also it has a lot
of plugins that can be used according to
your website needs blogger you can
create a beautiful blog using blogger
for free and it has also has free themes
which you can use still it is always
recommended that you use tools like
WordPress to build your website because
businesses need a website with lot of
functionalities and WordPress makes this
process easier the website requires
hosting as the next tool we have is
hostinger you need to purchase a domain
and hosting to host a website there are
other companies also available that you
can use to host your site such as
GoDaddy HostGator Etc hosting J provides
automatic backups that will ensure that
your website data is secured and allows
you to create unlimited subdomain which
is also necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use Infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website but for a
beginner just wanting to learn how
website hosting works you can use
Infinity free every Business website and
its social media platform need content
and and content is the oxygen of the
internet there is no surviving without
it but meeting the demand of a Content
hungry World often means that you are
forced to pull your hair out only to
throw more into the fire from research
to Creation to distribution content is
now 24x7 job requiring many internal
resources or costly outsourced help if
you are looking to cut down the cost and
streamline your efforts here are some
content creation tools to take your
business to the next level headline it
is an AI tool that will create a landing
page automatically no writing designing
and coding is required you need to give
information about the product and it is
also has buil-in templates to use it
became famous because of this feature
but now it is upgraded and you will see
a lot of other features that will help
you create excellent content it is a
paid tool but you can try its free
version pepper type it is a one stop AI
solution tool for all content needs and
the best part is you will get 10,000
World limit to try out this fantastic
tool the specialty of this tool is that
it allows you to create content for
specific social media platforms and long
form
content grammarly grammarly is a free
online tool that find mistakes in your
writing and suggest improvements as you
write grammarly will underline any
mistakes you have made and offer
suggestions on how to fix them
additionally it has a plagarism checker
and a punctuation
checker however for additional features
you need to go with grammarly premium
the best way to create excellent content
is to have good visuals this is why we
have listed the best designing tools
that you can use to get stock images and
videos canva you can design your website
using canva for free it is the best tool
to make your website content more
engaging in it is a simple drag and drop
tool that allows you to create beautiful
Graphics Flyers infographics social
media posts and more you can also use it
to create more engaging images for your
post furthermore it gives you free
templates and allows you to collaborate
with your business team using team
functionality pixabay pixabay is a free
website or a creative community that
shares copyright free photos
illustrations music and videos all piab
content are licensed under the pixa
license you can use them without asking
for permission or crediting the artist
even for commissional
purposes you can download these stock
images videos musics and illustration
without signing up shutter stock
although it also comes with the same
feature the key difference is that it is
paid you might wonder why to use this
shutter stock since we already have a
free tool like pixa well it depends on
your business needs there are some
images and stock footage that you will
only find on C stock in addition C stock
has powerful editing tools and custom
siiz options that attract people now we
have a better understanding of the
content part in order to attract more
visitors the content needs to be
promoted the following tools will help
you promote your business Drive traffic
to your website convert visitors into
leads build brand awareness Etc Google
ads Google ads are a powerful tool tool
that can help you reach your target
audience it is small but significant
step towards online Success Through many
people believe that Google ads are not
as effective as they used to be there
are still more benefits than drawbacks
the only thing you need to know how to
use it your website can be advertised
via Google ads and your product and
services can be promoted on YouTube it
has an excellent feature lead form
extension that allow user to provide
their contact details directly ly
through the ad without visiting your
landing page additionally life events
targeting for example graduating from a
college is also a great feature since it
helps you reach the correct type of
audience Facebook ads manager it allows
you to run Facebook and Instagram ads
and it's an excellent way to promote
your business a feature like Facebook
analytics will give you a good grasp of
data feature like audience Insight will
better understand who is interested in
your product and Services Google ads and
Facebook ads require you to spend money
on ads by setting up a daily or a custom
budgets buas suumo is a Content
marketing tool to help you find the best
ways of engaging creating and spreading
content across social and search
channels two of the best feature is
finding an influencer that will help you
to find the right influencer and a
Content Discovery feature which will
help you to discover new content ideas
email marketing tools are the most
effective means to stay in touch with
your customers you can nurture leads
rearrange with your audience and build a
subscriber base through email businesses
today recognize the importance of email
and marketers are investing heavily in
email marketing tools however in the
overwhelming sea of email marketing
tools finding the right fit can be
tricky we have selected some of the best
email marketing tools to help your
business get started and grow through
2022 MailChimp MailChimp is a
comprehensive marketing platform that
lets you keep track of and communicate
with your clients customers and other
interested parties but it is popular
because of its email Services there is a
free plan of MailChimp the free plan is
often more than enough for small
businesses up to 2,000 subscribers can
be added and 12,000 emails can be sent a
month it supports multiple integration
to integrate other thirdparty softwares
and MailChimp also allows you to update
or remove the subscriber profiles which
is also one of the best feature of
MailChimp send in blue it is very
similar to MailChimp both have excellent
and similar features when it comes to
email Services one unique feature of
send in blue is that it has a option of
a drag and drop Builder that is
accessible by mobile analyzis and
optimization businesses need to analyze
and optimize their processes to grow
furthermore you should analyze the data
to develop a solution to the problem
problems in your industry several tools
can be beneficial here let's discuss
that Google search console this tool
will help you understand how your
website performs on Google searches by
ranking on top you will have higher
chances of attracting more visitors the
index coverage report will help you
understand which web page have problems
moreover it has a very useful URL
inspection tool which gives information
about Google's indexed page version vid
IQ many YouTubers majorly use it to
analyze their performance on YouTube and
optimize their Channel if you are
looking to rank your video on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description and tags this tool helps you
to do
that the tool includes a thumbnail
generator that lets you create
customized thumbnails that generate good
views and it as Trend alerts which will
notify you by email of popular content
Google analytics using Google analytics
you can track the traffic on your
website and find out where your visitors
are coming from it also allows you to
track your sales performance and traffic
sources Google analytics is a tool that
will let you know if your website is
performing well and also if you need to
make some changes to improve its
performance it has outstanding features
like funnel analysis and smart goals a
funnel is a method for determining which
steps are necessary to achieve the
desired outcomes and with smart goals
you can identify and count the most
engaged users on your website user
Behavior user Behavior tools help you
understand user behavior on the website
user Behavior tools are very effective
tools used in digital marketing to track
the behavior of visitors and make the
business more effective below are the
some of the user Behavior tools used in
digital marketing H jaob hotjar is an
inside tool that lets you analyze your
customer behavior and get feedback to
understand them better and come up with
new business strategies to grow your
business this tool gives you visual
feedback which you won't find in other
tools and it also offer surveys which is
also a unique feature of orja smart look
it is mostly similar to H ja but it has
some additional features like
customizable dashboard and conversion
funnel which means the visualization of
how people follow the path competitor
analysis many businesses start their
competitive study when planning their
digital marketing strategy and then
abandon it it is essential to make
adjustments after competitor analysis
and use great tools here are some of the
best the tool is completely paid you can
use this tool to improve your PPC
campaign as it gives you insight into
what your competitors are doing keywords
can also be imported as well as
downloaded social blade it is used for
social media monitoring and influencer
tracking for example you can get lot of
information about the performance of
other competitors and how they are doing
on YouTube and other social media
channels the best part is that many
features are available in the free plan
similar web it is also an excellent tool
to analyze competitors website traffic
and you can also get the Google Play and
Apple App Store data href we already
covered this in the research category
but we wanted to mention it here because
h F will also be viewed as one of the
best tools for analyzing
competitors communication starting and
building a successful business require
better communication within your team we
must ensure that our task has been
clearly communicated to the team so that
we will be able to perform the work as
we intended thus one needs a tool to
accomplish that so now let's check out
some of the best tools for
communication slack the app is a chat
room that brings together all of your
team's Communication in one place
meaning there is a no longer a need to
use email Skype or multi chat room apps
slack can be used with both work and
personal accounts and it can benefit
businesses in several different ways
Microsoft teams it is also similar to
slack but it offers unlimited app
integration and unlimited chat messages
there are free plans for both but you
can upgrade if your business need aren M
here what you have learned so far
initially we discussed research then
tools to build and host the website next
we discussed content creation and
graphic designing tools after that we
discussed tools that will help in the
promotion and then the email marketing
tools after that we discussed analysis
and optimization tools next we discussed
user behavior and competitor analysis
tools and finally we discuss the
communication Tools digital marketing
plays an presential role in most
businesses today this has led to an
increase in the demand for digital
marketing professionals because of this
many people are interested in learning
about digital marketing it is becoming
one of the essential skills that you can
have if you learn how to use it you can
make a difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I'm Tushar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we will discuss the top 10
reasons to learn digital marketing but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube YouTu Channel
and hitting that Bell icon to stay
tuned so without any further delay let's
get
started easy to start a career a career
in digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training in
digital marketing as a lot of free and
paid resources are available a Technical
and creative field both Technical and
creative skills are necessary for
digital marketing it has a lot of
subfield hence it requires a unique
skill set and knowledge of the latest
technology for example a social media
marketing professional should know how
to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical
Fields highly paid digital marketing is
one of the most popular and trending
Industries there is a v demand for
digital marketing professionals as a
result digital marketing roles are also
very well paid your expertise could help
you gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman sax report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by 2025 which shows
the extent of digital marketing in India
and the job demand for digital marketing
according to glass door a digital
marketing manager earns around 7 lakh in
India and HEI can earn roughly
$123,000 in the
US become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online also you can start your
own freelancing business where you can
offer various services to the clients
all aspiring Entre R preneurs need to
embrace digital marketing and even the
old ones need to adapt in order to
grow career growth there are lot of
digital marketing professionals around
but very few are skilled the demand for
digital marketing skills will increase
in the near future due to digital
economy's rapid growth many individuals
are starting their online businesses and
almost every new company starts with an
online presence hence it's a perfect
chance for individuals who are looking
to make a career in digital
marketing the next reason is
versatility digital marketing offers a
variety of career options and a lifetime
learning since there are so many aspects
to it for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for 2 years and now
you want to work in SEO in that case
there is relatively little training you
need so it won't be that difficult to
switch over if you want to enter into
some other domain your digital marketing
experience will always be valuable
therefore it is is said that digital
marketers can easily change
jobs the next major reason is more
number of jobs several new jobs were
created in the digital marketing field
after coid as most businesses came
online you will find many digital
marketing job opportunities on LinkedIn
every single day Grand View research
reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56 billion in 2021 and is expected to
grow at a compound annual growth rate C
of
19.1% from 2022 to
2030 the field of digital marketing is
vast however digital marketing is also
used in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trustworthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain time and cost
effective in the long term digital
marketing will save you a lot of time
effort effort and money traditional
marketing is expensive and the cost keep
Rising there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of
efforts the next important reason is
Recession Proof job lending your dream
job is a rarity for many in this job
market with the economy still struggling
businesses are cutting jobs left and
right so how you can make yourself
Recession Proof if you are creative and
willing to learn it can happen there are
many ways to make yourself more
desireable to businesses and get job
offers however one way is to become an
expert in digital marketing digital
marketing is the internet-based
marketing of product and services using
digital Technologies mainly on the
internet marketing is is an integral
part of any business with the ever
growing number of Internet users it is
expected that more companies will use
digital marketing extensively in the
future so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of
specializations SEO content marketing
influencer marketing sem and many other
fall under digital marketing an
individual has a lot to explode and once
you explode you can pick a digital
Market specialization according to your
interest additionally there is a wide
variety of skills that you need to
master under each of these categories
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn happy New Year and
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing skills so digital marketing
allows business owners regardless of the
business nonprofit for-profit large or
small National local International to
really expand their business
allows them to personalize their content
they could save money and most
importantly they can measure the results
and so that's where we're going to focus
on today we talk about digital marketing
skills focusing on measuring the results
so suppose anybody wants to work in
marketing or grow a company or help grow
an individual's company or and sure to
keep up with the appropriate skills this
is what we're going to cover today so
we're going to cover a few Chan
and so let's get right to it today we're
going to start off with search engine
optimization or SEO also known as
organic search so
SEO is an interesting channel uh it's
probably the premier channel for most
companies in fact HubSpot confirms that
57% of B2B marketers stated that SEO
generates more leads than any other
marketing initiative so it's really
important for not only just generating
traffic but it's also important for
generating leads and and generating more
business including e-commerce and so
what does SEO entail and what skills
should you acquire in order to manage
SEO as a marketing channel well if you
think about it SEO is really divied up
into two Pi one pie is called on page
the other pie is called off- page and so
on page consist of things you can do to
the website to help you be found in
organic search so what are those things
well it could be anything from you know
page load speed to four four errors to
sitemaps and so the point here is if
you're going to manage SEO and you know
that you got to make sure your website's
in tiptop shape or your client's
websites and good good enough shape for
Google to recognize it as a legitimate
site you have to have some technical
skills now I'm not saying you have to be
developer but at the same time you have
to know what a 44 eror is you know have
to know where and how to generate a site
map and upload that sitemap you need to
know how to edit a robot's text file so
those are you know what I call soft
technical skills but they're all valid
for SEO so you have to have some
technical background staying in the on
page piie okay you need to make sure you
have not only skills to write content
but skills to optimize content so you
need to be aware of all the different
elements on a page in order to optimize
that page so again that entails you know
some copywriting skills but more
importantly and probably more
challenging is to take those
copyrighting skills and enhance them for
SEO okay so making sure that you're able
to understand what it is that you need
to do to get a page optimized so it can
rank higher in the search engine results
okay so those are on page
skills then you got the other piece of
the P which is off page so understanding
you know what it takes to make sure your
site is relevant so it's understanding
different metrics off page metric like
page Authority domain Authority external
links internal legs and so generally
most SEO managers have a thirdparty SEO
platform that they work with like SCM
rush or MZ so it's understanding how to
work with those platforms to measure
off-page results so we always say that
SEO as a digital marketing channel is an
800B gorilla well it is because you have
on page and off page to worry about so
the two of those together you know is is
quite a task in order to rank and so
what brings SEO and all digital
marketing channels is understanding the
metrics and understanding what you're
seeing in order to measure results and
improve upon those results okay so
that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do I measure
the results and so when we look at SEO
in terms of measuring results
on the onpage side okay you're going to
have to do some keyword analysis you're
going to have to understand okay what
volume is you're going to understand how
to get the competition numbers okay and
you're going to have to understand what
key wordss to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain Authority
or page Authority you have external
links internal links you have no follow
and follows and and you all these little
metrics related to off-page seos you're
going to have to understand what those
metrics mean and if you can understand
what those metrics mean and then more
importantly act on those metrics then
that's what's going to help you improve
your results in terms of SEO so again
that's going to be the common theme here
so I'm just going to highlight again
those metrics that you're going to need
to understand in order to better manage
SEO a channel again on the on page side
you need to understand the
technicalities involved but for example
page load what's a good page load time
what's a bad page load time from a
keyword perspective what's good volume
what's bad volume what's good
competition what's bad competition so if
you can understand understand the
intricacies of the measurements related
to SEO then that'll help you improve
upon this big Channel called organic
search so SEO is the practice of getting
relevant traffic to the website okay
from organic search results so it really
is essential to stay up to
dat and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search and ranking okay so
that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads payperclick cost per click a lot of
acronyms a lot of ways to describe it at
the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
Advertiser have the ability and have the
opportunity to rank at the very top of
the Google search search results now
it's different than SEO because you're
actually paying for the placement and so
to be found at the top of the search
engine results as a paid placement or
sponsored ad means that if somebody
clicks on your ad you're going to pay
Google X amount okay so unlike SEO sem
is very fast moving and so when we talk
about fast moving we mean that you're
collecting a lot of data very quickly
so sticking with the theme of what
skills should I have for search engine
marketing well if you're going to
collect data then that means you need to
measure the results of that data and so
sticking with our theme of measureing
results you need to understand first and
foremost what all the different metrics
mean related to centr engine marketing
okay so I'm just going to Rattle off if
you will a few of the metrics but the
commonality here is yes you can learn
what those metrics mean but you have to
act on those metrics so one of the the
main metrics involved with search engine
marketing is Impressions so impression
is just basically how many people have
seen your ad okay so if your ad shows up
on the search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
seen you're ad what's a lot of
impressions well it's objective okay so
it could be th000 Impressions or 10,000
Impressions at the end of the day that's
how many people have seen your ad now
more
importantly you have another metric
called clicks clicks means how many
people actually saw your ad and then
clicked on your ad okay so if you have
100 people that have seen your ad and
one person who clicked on your ad then
you have a click through rate of
1% now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have High click through rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay to Quality score simply a number
between one and 10 that's assigned to
each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you
have 200 or 300 or 500 or a th000
Impressions and very little click that
means your clickthrough rate is going to
be low if your clickthrough rate is
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low and in order to pay
less to Google you need to make sure
that your quality score is good so you
need to understand the factors involved
with quality score you need to
understand Impressions clicks click
through rate because if you don't have a
good click theough rate then how do you
improve that so it's about measuring the
results and acting upon the results
those are the skills involved with
search engine marketing and that's just
on the click side you got the conversion
side of the house so you need to be able
to understand how to get
conversions and how to maintain a high
conversion rate so for example if you
have 100 clicks and only one
conversion that is a 1% conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say $20 and you're only
selling a product that's say
$10 well then you got a problem and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low click the rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion or very low Impressions you
need to be able to understand
how to react to what you're seeing and
what data you're collecting that to me
is the primary skill bottom line with
search engine marketing and there are
other skill sets involved don't get me
wrong I mean it's nice to be able to
write copy because with search engine
marketing typically the ads have very
few characters involved so you need to
be able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing copy
being able to understand your target
audience um those are all things
involved with managing searching of
marketing but really the key component
here is again measuring the results okay
let's switch over to a traditional
marketing channel email marketing you
know one of my favorites you know listen
we're all bombarded with
emails uh and you know what it it
becomes cumbersome at times I mean it's
easy to just to regard an email and so
to me the key here if you're going to do
email
marketing you need to have a certain set
of skill sets and so what that skill set
is is really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of
recipients you need to hope that that
email is relevant to that audience okay
so you need to be able to really
identify who it is we're sending this
email
to and a recent study done by
statista uh stated that 49% of consumers
really like to receive promotional
emails from their favorite Brands so if
you have a very strong brand then email
marketing is probably a good channel for
you if you don't have a strong brand or
nobody really knows about your brand or
your product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will but
really email Market marketing is it
involves emails that promote the brands
products and
services and if you could Target the
Right audience or making sure you have
the Right audience then you got a good
chance of having successful email
marketing
campaigns but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copyrighting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copywriting saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email they're going to be able
to react to it so you know writing copy
with strong call to action or really
relevant copy that really talks to the
audience I mean those are all keys for
email marketing in my
opinion also one thing we didn't bring
up in search engine marketing but it
certainly holds true with search engine
marketing as well as email marketing and
that's AB testing and so AB testing is
simply taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs well you could certainly do
AV testing with email marketing that
means taking a subject line that has
traditionally work for you or is
relevant for that audience and then
creating a variant or different sub line
so if I'm going to send an email to 100
people I'm going to send
50 people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variant
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to okay so if I see the
open rates higher for the variant versus
the traditional or the original subject
line then I know that this subject line
works and therefore I'm going to apply
this subject line moving forward and
then what am I going to do I'm going to
take it and test it against another
variant so you should always do AB
testing on subject lines so the concept
of AB testing should not be lost on any
digital Market okay whether that be SEO
search engine marketing or email
marketing okay so you should have an
understanding of AB testing and of
course going back to measuring results
with email you have a different set of
metrics we already mentioned open rates
so if you send out 100 emails how many
people open the email okay you want that
open rate to be as high as possible and
then when they open the email did people
click on that CTA or any of those links
in the email okay so you want a high
click the rate and then more importantly
when they click on a link in the email
they're going to go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so what's the engagement
rate of the landing page from the email
okay so it's really important that you
have an understanding of all the
different metrics involved with email
marketing and again how to react to that
data so if you're getting a low open
rate could it be the subject line isn't
that good possibly that's why you have
to do testing if you're getting a low
click rate on the emails that could be
because the copy may not be that great
or the design or the C action or it's
not compelling enough for the recipient
of the email and then again the
engagement r on the landing page if you
have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate you got to look at that
and figure out how to improve that okay
so you can apply AB testing the landing
pitch so there are always ways to react
to the data regardless of what campaign
or regardless of what digital marketing
channel you're working in okay so that's
the commonality here one point on email
marketing is if you're going to measure
the results of the campaign whether
you're using you know vertical response
or MailChimp or you know some other
email marketing platform you want to
make sure you have what we call UTM
tracking and if you're using Google
analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign in Google
analytics so that's another skill set
you should have being able to apply you
know tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email okay because
if you don't it's going to be hard to
measure the results in Google analytics
so let's focus on one more marketing
channel here and that's social media so
we all know social media isn't going
anywhere it's becoming more and more
popular in fact you know offshoot of
social media is really influencer
marketing uh you know if somebody an
influencer has millions of likes on say
Tik Tok or Instagram you might want to
engage with that influencer and help you
promote your brand or your product isn't
that really what social media is it's a
platform whether that be you know
Facebook or or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to get to message your
user base your community perspective
clients people who don't don't even know
about your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me see there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a large
percentage the majority of the
percentage of the world uses a social
media platform okay in fact just like
SEO where you need an SEO platform there
are plenty of social media platforms
there's later there's Sprout social
there's hoote there's buffer in fact
buffer confirmed that 73% of marketers
believe social media marketing has been
somewhat effective or very effective for
their business and that's promising
because social media in my
opinion having been in this industry a
while
it can be a very fickle Channel meaning
if you're trying to promote a product or
service on
Facebook and it's very very going to be
very hard to pull that person away who's
engaged with their Facebook feed not
only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and
convert okay based on what you have on
your website so it's challenging enough
just to get them away from the social
media platform let alone converting so
that's why when I say very fickle but
you know somewhat encouraging if buffers
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing can be effective
and it can be effective you just have to
have the right strategy so to me one of
the skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to
achieve when we set up a social media
platform or enact a social media
campaign okay and so that's really the
first thing it's really understanding
what platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because because the last
thing you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content because just
like any other marketing channel you're
going to have
metrics and social media is not shy on
the metric front Okay so you have
reach you have Impressions you have
engagement rate in fact every social
media channel has its own set of
specific metrics whether that be likes
followers
shares uh uh reviews Stars if you will
so it really depends on the social media
platform that you're using but at the
end of the day you need to be able to
measure the results if you're posting
let's just say on
Facebook and your whole job or strategy
is to entice engagement meaning get
people to share that particular post or
act on that post then you need to be
able to measure the engagement how many
people saw the post how many people
engag with the post okay and so just
like any other marketing channel you're
collecting data and you need to react to
that data but more
importantly it's about being able to you
know put a strategy together
first and then I would you know a skill
set I would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just name buffer or hoot sweet or
social they're all good in their own
right but they're all going to have
different features so to
me understanding what social media
platform works best for you you want to
choose a social media platform that you
know allows you to control what post you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on at the same time you want a
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the engagement that
you're getting from that
platform and you probably want a social
media platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will um what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform okay so you want a
listening tool if you will uh as part of
that social media platform so it's
understanding what platform you want to
use when it comes to social media
marketing it's understanding what
strategy that that platform is going to
help you en enact okay and then it it's
also that social media platform that's
going to help you understand the data so
you can react to the
data so those are all to me the skill
sets you need as a social media manager
and then an a shoot of social media is
paid social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
your ad on LinkedIn and somebody clicks
on it you're going to pay for that click
you're going to pay LinkedIn or you're
going to pay Twitter you're going to pay
Facebook so it's understanding you know
the skill sets involved with paid social
is understanding what assets you can
have when advertising on these platforms
you know can you use video on LinkedIn
or
Facebook um you know can you use what
type of images and you know how big do
those images need to be and can you have
in on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your
ads so having a full understanding of
the types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole another set of
metrics you know how many people saw
your ad how many people clicked on your
ad how many people engaged with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid
social so you have the opportunity on
paage social you have the opportunity on
social media to to really get your
message out there it's really
understanding what kind of data you're
collecting what are the results of the
ad or the post and how do you react to
that and that's really the common theme
with digital marketing skills if you're
not a big fan of numbers you're not a
big fan of excel if you will or
spreadsheets if looking at a mountain of
data scares you well then you might want
to think otherwise when going into
digital marketing but if you want to
embrace the data then digital marketing
is really a great career because if you
get the data and you know how to react
to the data then you can be successful
in any campaign you run right that
should so if you are an aspiring digital
marketer then have a look at simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing obtain certification as
digital marketing professional through
Pur University program acquire the
knowledge to develop and advertise your
personal website so hurry up and enroll
Now find the cost Link in the
description box now we have reached the
most exciting and essential part of the
video average salary of a digital
marketing manager in the digital
marketing industry there is a huge
demand for digital marketing managers
and their salaries reflect that several
factors determine the income a person
can expect including experience the size
of your company your location and your
industry digital advertising has proven
to be more convenient and effective than
traditional advertising since most of
your audience is online as a result
digital marketing is growing and become
becoming more popular a digital
marketing manager plays a significant
role in drawing Revenue into the
business and due to their highly
result-driven nature their salaries are
high a digital marketing managers earns
approximately 6 lakh 72,000 per year in
India and in the US he or she can earn
roughly
$75,000 per
[Music]
year lastly let's discuss the future of
digital marketing Grand View research
reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56.52% from 2022 to
2030 you have looked into the new
digital marketing trends at some point
if you are aspiring or experienced
digital marketer the best way to succeed
in digital marketing is to keep up with
current trends in the field now we will
look at the two trending technologies
that use digital marketing and are on
the rise blockchain the data from
digital advertising campaign can
sometimes be inaccurate so Improvement
can be difficult monitoring marketing
campaigns in real time is achievable
with blockchain for obtaining
trustworthy metrics top brands such as
unil are applying blockchain for
improving digital advertising efficiency
successfully augmented and virtual
reality Starbucks Nivea and Volkswagen
all launch successfully AR and VR
campaigns to better connect their brands
and products to their customer it is
undeniable that these two technologies
are booming and expected to grow
massively in the next few years the use
of digital marketing in these
Technologies makes us aware the bright
future of digital marketing thank you
for joining and today we're going to
cover digital marketing interview
questions and answers so thanks for
joining again and here's how it's going
to work so we broke out a few questions
and answers uh in different categories a
lot of you are going to be interviewing
for some jobs out there and some of the
jobs may be an SEO manager or search
engine marketing manager or email
marketing manager or content marketing
manager or social media manager so we
broke up those questions into those
areas and so that's what we're going to
do we're going to start with SEO we're
going to go through some questions and
I'm going to explain
the answers to those questions so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
as soon as possible so let's get started
we're going to start with SEO search
engine optimization we're going to go
through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you taken or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site B we're
going to basically tell Google Bing and
some of these other search engines hey
go ahead and follow that link now no
follow is just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site site a pointing to site
B we can put a no follow tag in there
and what that's going to do it's going
to signal to the Crawlers hey don't
follow this link so in the end if the
Crawlers don't follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
passed and so Google is not going to
give you credit or give that site credit
for having a link pointing to it or
pointing to to another site or from
another site and so it's all about
linking so we can control if there's
links on our site whether we want the
Crawlers to recognize those or not
simply with no follow text so just a
reminder link ju is the reputation or
Equity pass from one website to another
so if you have a link on another website
and that website is of high quality
meaning their page Authority their
domain Authority is high they have a lot
of content you know they're not spam
they're really rich and they're relevant
then you may want to make sure that the
link pointing from that site to your
site is a no follow so that way that
Google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
no follow and why would we do a no
follow well it depends it really depends
a lot of social media platforms like
Facebook have no follows if you have a
lot of content you may not want to be
pushing out a lot of du follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice on to and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an SEO perspective if I have a site
and I have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites I'm
going to be particular about who I allow
the search engine to follow follow and
what links I allow not to follow so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the hre
notice the no follow has the the tag
appended to it the hre tag with a no
follow so if the search engines crawling
your site and they see that no follow
there they're not going to follow that
link and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyw here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we don't have a
page anymore we have a new page let's
just say you built a new website with
new URLs you want to make sure the old
page is pointing to the new page with a
301 redirect so if a 301 redirect is
permanent then a 302 is temporary so we
want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might alert Google to not keep
that page in its search engine rankings
because it's temporary so why would
Google want to keep a temporary page or
even a page that is pointing to another
page on a temporary basis so they REM
May remove both pages from its index
okay but if we have something permanent
in place Google may say okay this page
is permanently linking to another page
or redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are back links important in
SEO well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the no follow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and has a
high page and domain Authority then it's
going to benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from high quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a doe follow tag so
the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointed to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a lineon share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an onpage
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases
their D domain Authority Google sees
this is more relevant therefore pages
are going to benefit by ranking higher
and therefore when we rank high we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO cuz videos are found
YouTube and itself S as a search engine
so if we have a video how are we going
to get it to rank on YouTube well first
things first you never want to put a
video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a type title that has
high search volume and low difficulty
just as you would keyword for example
for a web page you want to choose a
title with a keyword in it that has high
volume and low difficulty I.E low
competition okay so you want a nice
ratio there and you know when you want
to choose a title it's going to get
people to watch the video too so it's
not all about just choosing a title just
for the sake of high volume you also
have to choose something that's relevant
that's going to be catchy as well and
then with that title goes the
description so you want a description
that's very relevant to your title okay
because most people aren't going to
click on a video just for the sake of
the title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter or Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informed if you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
going to like it and then other people
are going to see that engagement they're
going to see how many people liked it or
how many subscribers you have so promote
your videos to help you with the ranking
of the video on YouTube so that does
play into it so go ahead and promote it
so other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using using mobile friendly content
for indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so if that smartphone
bot goes to your website and starts
crawling what do you think they're
looking for their smartphone bought
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets index
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked this question you could even take
it a step further and say look I'm going
to measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bot and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asked you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mo mobile usab
ility report okay number six list down
the most important local SEO ranking
factors okay so organic local ranking is
just as important as anything else in
organic search because if you have a
local business you want to use the likes
of say Google my business to show up
when somebody types in you know looking
for a florist or you're looking for a
coffee shop so what you want to do is
you want to create a web page for every
product and service okay you also want
to opt for your business listings on
Google my business and and there are
plenty of other local business
directories out there like Yelp for
example or Bing even has one so go ahead
and also make sure you have a business
listing as well but since Google in the
United States has a huge market share
you want to start with Google first you
want to update your nap citations on
your website maintain consistency of
your nap okay so nap is name address
phone number so you want to make sure
that that's current and consistent so if
you have a number on your website make
sure it's the same number on Google my
business okay you can embed a Google map
on your website you could certainly
optimize the metatags and content not
only on your web pages but within your
Google my business directory so you can
add your business to other local
directories like I mentioned Yelp and
then also just as a important op for
reviews and ratings okay so the more
reviews the H you have the better off
you are okay so I always say this with
or with local search three of the main
factors in showing up for local search
on say Google is obviously the keyword
the second is the proximity of where
that person is and then third is the
reviews so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
key wordss let's just say for your
product and service pages on your
website but also you can translate that
over to Google my business okay so
working in those keywords making sure
your your number your address your name
they're all consistent and and really
just spreading your the the business out
on other directories that's really all
these are really key factors for local
SEO okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
seo11 you never want to have two two or
more pages with the same content so what
do we do well we can avoid this and
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember 301's
are permanent we can also use what they
call a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is op for
preferred domain in Google search
console okay so if you have multiple
domains make sure you set up a primary
one in search console so those are ways
to work around it of this three I would
always go with the Canon tags because
that's just a tag that's going to sit on
the page it's going to alert Google as
to what the original is just in case
they get their hands on the duplicate so
all the pages that have the same content
are going to have the same canonical tag
pointing to one page so again three ones
are permanent you could simply just
redirect one to the other if you end up
having duplication or you could just
tell the search engines hey this is the
original page or you can go through
search console okay number eight what
are the tactics to increase a web page
speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible what I mean by
simple as possible really I mean hey use
a simple website design don't get overly
creative if you will most websites all
websites have images you're not going to
be able to get around that but just make
sure you optimize your images and other
words don't have such a large image size
if you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time and what do we mean
by that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and it's
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have a an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for SEO okay optimize your code we
mean by optim minifying when we say
minifying we mean get rid of some of the
redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
reduce redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cach version of
that page and then opt for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website you can always go
to Google's page speed insights tool and
all you have to do is just Google page
speed insights or even just something
generic like Google page speed and
you're going to get this tool page speed
insights and all you need to do is just
plug in a URL when you plug in the URL
Google's going to analyze the URL for
both mobile and desktop and so here we
could see Google gives the score so we
could see the score for mobile and we
could see the score for desktop just by
clicking on desktop and so here I could
see some of the issues that the site may
be having in terms of page low time for
their desktop if I flip over to mobile
you know here I could see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
and or you can just always Google it as
well uh here you got the reduce the
impact of third party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
JavaScript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should we'll tend to slow
down the
okay so you can use page speed insights
you can always get a glimpse of how
pages are loading simply by also going
to for example Google analytics under
Behavior okay you can go to site speed
and if you click on overview okay Google
what Google does is they do a sampling
of pages over time and in this case
based on 89 Page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific Pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
Google analytics to get a sense of how
quick your pages are loading now there
are certain factors that do affect load
time so obviously the way the page is
built with the code the images Etc but
also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the United States and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know co uh Ivory Coast in Africa
okay so it really depends on the network
you're on so and also the page every
page is built differently so you want to
get a sense of what pages are loading
quicker and which pages are not you can
simply just go to page timings in Google
analytics and you get a sense of what
pages do not load fast which ones do to
and maybe hone in on the pages that
aren't loading fast and address those
pages first okay so you have two tools
that your disposal one Google analytics
and one page speed insights okay so
let's look at question number nine here
so when should an individual Target
short tail and longtail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very Broad in nature
longtail keywords maybe three four key
words in a query or maybe an entire
sentence those are considered longtail
keyw so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower uh volume but also lower
competition but the great thing about
longtail keywords the conversion rate
will tend to be a little bit higher than
say a short tail because it's less vague
and more specific so you can use short
tail keywords if you're trying to drive
a lot of visitors because because those
keywords are going to be vague or Broad
in nature longtail keywords are used for
targeted Pages such as product pages and
article so if you have a specific
product with a long name you can
certainly optimize that page for that
product name again the product name may
have low volume but if somebody types in
exactly that product name you show up
the chance of you them converting are
going to be very high so you don't have
to always be that specific at the
product name but try and be as specific
as you possibly can in order to get
somebody to click on your link in the
search engine results and get them over
to your site to convert okay so those
are really the big differences short
tail very broad very vague a lot of
volume but also a lot of competition but
hey if you're ranking for short tail
keyword you're probably going to get a
lot of traffic the conversion rates may
not be as high as something say longtail
where hey maybe you're just toned in on
a few set number of products and you're
not care you don't care a lot about the
traffic you just care about getting the
relevant traffic to your site to convert
okay number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody asked me this
question in an interview what am I going
to focus on while developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to the index with Google
smartphone bot so mobile usability is
very important so we need to make sure
our website is responsive for mobile
just some basic practices when it comes
to site architecture navigation we want
to have a simple URL structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and need okay if you
have five products okay maybe you have
uh in your navigation you have something
called products with all five listed or
you have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat easy for somebody
to find the the rule of thumb is if it's
good for the end user probably going to
be good for Google but if complicated
for the end User it's probably going to
be complicated for Google you always
want to create a sitemap now what is
that sitemap a sitemap is simply just a
formatted file with to that's includes
all your URLs and assets your images and
your videos they're going to be sitting
on your server as well so you want
Google or these these Bots to be able to
find your pages and assets and by the
way you want to take it a step further
and make sure you upload that site map
which is sitting in the root directory
meaning
domain.com sitemap.xml okay you want to
take that sitemap and make sure you
input that sitemap location in Google
search console that way Google search
console has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a wipe side is having a
robot's text file and all A robot's text
file is it's like a lock I always say to
a house so if you lock a door in your
house nobody's going to be able to get
in that door so it's all what robots
text file is you're telling Google and
these other Bots that are coming ACR
your site what's locked and what's not
locked meaning what they have access to
what they don't have access to so you
want to be able to make sure you have a
robot's text file if you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell Google don't crawl
these Pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled and if they
don't get crawled they're not going to
get indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
cuz it's my new website I'm not ready to
go live yet so you don't want an indexed
so there are a lot of reasons to have
robots text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want Google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your site architect or
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when I say content I don't necessarily
just mean words I also mean videos I
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if if an end user finds your site
engaging Google is likely going to find
your side engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just a recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so that Bots can easily access
and mix content okay with a responsive
design helps to make your website mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
Bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robots text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house then give it that way
here we wrap up this full course looking
forward to get certified in digital
marketing have a look at digital
marketing master's program by simply
learn which is the One-Stop solution for
all your needs a year of experience is
preferred for this course apply code
ytb5 to get discount on your purchase
find the cost Link in the description
box if you have have any questions feel
free to add them in the comment section
and our experts will be happy to help
you thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
Computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
Channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here